la séance est ouverte mais chers
collègues nous avons le plaisir cet
après-midi de recevoir la Nathalie
Loiseau ancienne ministre des affaires
européennes actuellement député
européenne et sous-président de la
commission sécurité défense du Parlement
européen
présidentielle excusez-moi excusez-moi
nous sommes tous en tout cas moi aussi
excusez-moi madame la ministre
présidente de la sous-commission
sécurité défense du Parlement européen
et ce qui est bien suivi la
l'audition de Monsieur gluten vous êtes
aussi rapportrice ou rapporteur pardon
de la Ligue 1
il est dedans voilà donc ça commence
bien madame madame madame madame
la ministre je vous remercie de vous
être rendu disponible pour répondre à
nos questions
aux fonctions
que j'évoquais il faut ajouter cette
présidente de la délégation permanente
du Parlement européen à l'Assemblée
parlementaire Union européenne
Royaume-Uni et celle de coordinatrice du
groupe rognoux au sein de la commission
spéciale ING2 donc j'aurais dû faire
confiance à administrateur dont nous
avons attendu le président Rafael Luxman
mardi dernier vous avez publié il y a
quelques mois un ouvrage intitulé la
guerre qu'on ne voit pas venir consacré
aux nouveaux champs de conflictualité ou
des puissances hostiles ou amicales des
poids une activité toujours croissante
votre expérience votre expertise et vos
analyses nous seront donc précieuses et
nous permettront d'approfondir l'analyse
des phénomènes d'ingérence étrangères
que nous minons depuis plusieurs mois
cette audition est retransmise en direct
sur le site de l'Assemblée nationale
l'enregistrement vidéo sera ensuite
disponible à la demande cette commission
est aussi ouverte à la presse madame la
ministre vous aurez la parole pour une
intervention limitée d'une quinzaine de
minutes si cela
de combien vous convient pour partager
qu'est-ce que cette commission en fait
vous inspire quelles sont les la nature
de des travaux que nous menons vous
inspire qui est qu'elle analyse vous en
fait et quelle information vous
souhaitez apporter à la représentation
nationale puis nous poursuivrons nos
échanges avec des questions de votre
serviteur de madame la rapporteur et des
commissaires ici présent je vous
rappelle madame la ministre au titre de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires les
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête parlementaire
doivent prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité aussi
madame la ministre je vous invite à
lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure je le jure
je vous remercie et vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
reporter je voudrais vous remercier de
m'entendre au sein de votre commission
d'enquête et vous dire que je me réjouis
que l'Assemblée nationale se penche au
travers de cette commission d'enquête
sur ce sujet si important des ingérences
étrangères d'autres pays l'ont fait et
c'est un peu comme le nuage de
Tchernobyl il n'y a aucune raison de
penser que ce qu'ils ont traversé n'a
pas touché notre pays il était donc
[Musique]
utile et important que l'Assemblée
nationale puisse se pencher sur ce
travail
j'ai vu au regardant le titre exact de
votre commission d'enquête l'angle que
vous y mettez sur la question de la
corruption des élites pour faire vite
vous avez raison parce que c'est un
sujet
sensible et important
difficile à documenter et donc difficile
à combattre mais important tout de même
parce qu'il fait partie des instruments
des ingérences au Parlement européen la
Commission 1g2 dont vous avez parlé et
dont je suis à la fois coordinatrice et
corps rapporteur
a mis l'accent notamment sur les
manipulations de l'information qui n'ont
rien de nouveau dans l'histoire du monde
mais qui à partir du moment où l'air
numérique est entrée en jeu ont pris une
dimension une rapidité une force sans
précédent et un G2 mais aussi l'accent
sur le fait que ce sont les démocraties
qui sont les plus visées non pas pour ce
qu'elles font mais pour ce qu'elles sont
les démocraties
visées par des régimes autoritaires qui
voient une concurrence à leur propre
mode de gouvernance et la particularité
des ingérences dont nous faisons l'objet
c'est souvent moins d'essayer de nous
convaincre qu'un pays étranger a des
qualités qui ne nous seraient pas par
une naturellement que d'essayer de
démontrer
euh le caractère dysfonctionnel de nos
propres pays
d'essayer de discréditer la démocratie
pour ce qu'elle est de nous faire croire
irréconciliable systématiquement divisé
et affaibli et c'est ce qu'on retrouve
largement à la fois dans des expériences
étrangères et dans les méthodes qui sont
utilisées par les pays qui s'adonnent à
ces ingérences je voudrais très
rapidement évidemment pas du tout de
manière exhaustive et je reviendrai aux
questions que vous voudrez me poser sur
des sujets précis donner quelques
éclairages étrangers avant d'arriver
directement sur la situation française
au vu de ces éclairages et je
commencerai assez naturellement par le
brexit dans la mesure où très près de
nous et très près dans le temps en 2016
un référendum à
fait quitter l'Union européenne au
Royaume-Uni on connaît le résultat on a
constaté la division qui s'est installée
au sein d'opinion publique britannique
entre brexitter et partisans du maintien
dans l'Union européenne ce que on sait
partiellement et pas totalement c'est la
nature de l'ingérence étrangère russe
dans cette campagne du brexit on le sait
parce qu'il y a une commission du
renseignement qui a rendu un rapport on
ne le sait que partiellement parce que
ce rapport a été en partie masquée à la
demande du gouvernement britannique ce
qui est tout de même préoccupant mais on
sait tout de même que le rapport conclu
je cite qu'il existe des preuves
substantielles que l’ingérence russe est
une pratique courante dans la vie
politique britannique d'une phrase forte
ce qu'on a pu documenter entre autres ce
sont les liens entre certains financeurs
de la campagne du livre et en
particulier l'un de ses principaux
financeurs avec la Russie
lien ne veut pas dire autre chose mais
liens quand même
ce que l'on a pu observer c'est
l'existence de très nombreux faux
comptes sur les réseaux sociaux ou
l'existence de bottes diffusant et
amplifiant des contenus probexit et
pilotés depuis la Russie et ce que l'on
constate aussi ce sont les déclarations
du patron de du parti de l'époque Yuki
rage dont on se souvient qu'il a dit
Vladimir Poutine et le leader que
j'admire le plus dont on se souvient
qu'on a beaucoup vu sur le chatouday et
qu'aujourd'hui encore quand il
intervient sur les réseaux télévisés
c'est pour dénigrer l'Ukraine et dire du
bien de la Russie voilà ce qu'on peut en
dire
un peu plus loin de nous dans l'espace
mais pas dans le temps la campagne
américaine de la présidentielle de 2016
une enquête a eu lieu confié au
procureur spécial Robert Muller qui a
conclu et là encore je cite que la
Russie était intervenu de manière
écrasante et systématique là encore des
mots forts
Robert Muller a d'ailleurs inculpé 13
ressortissant russe pour ingérence dont
Yves Kenny Prigogine déjà
l'un des directeurs de campagne de Trump
paulmanaphore à plaider coupable et a
reconnu des contacts avec la Russie
l'Internet donc ce qu'on appelle l'usine
atroline pregojin est à l'origine de
faux messages de soutien à Trump qui ont
touché plus de 150 millions d'Américains
plus de 4000 faux comptes plus de 50000
bottes mobilisées pour un coût estimé à
35 millions de dollars si on veut
chiffrer le coût de l'ingérence pour une
fois on le peut
35 millions de dollars
on constate aussi la conjonction entre
des hackers russes qui s'en sont pris à
la campagne de Madame Clinton à trois
reprises et WikiLeaks qui a diffusé le
contenu de ce hacking mais en mêlant
vrai contenu il faut documents
on reviendra si vous le souhaitez sur
les objectifs qui avaient pu être
poursuivis par la Russie dans ces deux
exemples frappants d'ingérence dans des
processus purement électoraux on
pourrait évidemment parler des Balkans
on devrait naturellement parler de
l'Ukraine mais je crois que pour le coup
tout le monde l'a à l'esprit dans
l'Union européenne est contenue du
travail que faire notre commission
spéciale de celui que j'ai fait de mon
côté et de mon travail en tant que
président de la sous-commission sécurité
et défense on voit
une
constante une relation forte entre la
Russie et les extrêmes droites
européennes c'est un choix qui a été
fait par des proches de Vladimir Poutine
d'abord Constantin mal of mais pas
seulement lui dans un document d'un des
collaborateurs de Constantin récent
puisqu'il date de 2021 et un document
qui a fuité on lit sans notre engagement
actif et notre soutien tangible au parti
conservateurs européen leur popularité
et leur influence en Europe ont continué
à baisser il faut restaurer les contacts
avec les parties réceptiques de manière
systématique pour contrer la politique
de sanctions de Bruxelles mais la
reprise de ce travail va demander un
niveau de confidentialité très différent
en raison du renforcement de
l'opposition à l'influence russe c'est
dit c'est clairement dit alors on le
voit en Italie Matteo Salvini qui avait
dit entre Poutine et allenzi je choisis
Poutine
c'est un choix particulier on l'a vu au
Pays-Bas très tôt 2014 Thierry baudet je
dirais une figure connue de l'extrême
droite
néerlandaise s'est fait connaître en
faisant campagne à l'époque contre la
corde association Union européenne
Ukraine et aussi en ayant que le crash
de du vol mh17 et puis être
[Musique]
commis par les séparatistes prorus ou
des Russes Odon basse en l'attribuant
aux Ukrainiens et à la CIA Manuela prix
puisque aujourd'hui
la procédure judiciaire est terminée et
que l'origine du crash ne fait plus de
12 alors un pays comme l'Allemagne
montre à la fois une proximité entre la
Russie et l'extrême droite allemande AFD
mais on sait que ça va beaucoup plus
loin je ne détaillerai pas parce que je
pense que ça a déjà été mentionné dans
cette commission d'enquête les liens de
Gerard Schneider avec la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine mais aussi d'autres
hommes et femmes politiques les liens
des entreprises également de avec la
Russie je dirais peut-être juste pour
rester sur l'aspect électoral 2021
l'année électorale allemande a vu le
château des à l'époque encore autorisé
renforcée significativement le nom de
ces journalistes en Allemagne et choisir
de couvrir avec une intensité sans
précédent tout ce qui relevait de la
défiance vaccinale et de l'opposition à
la politique de santé allemande
toujours en Europe peut-être un mot
rapide pour parler de la Catalogne parce
que les révélations sur les la recherche
de liens entre les indépendantistes
catalans et la Russie est relativement
récente
mais tout de même importante et
intéressante et là encore il s'agissait
d'une consultation électorale même si
elle n'était pas officielle voilà pour
la Russie je m'en voudrais naturellement
de ne pas parler de la Chine la Chine
dont on connaît à travers l'Union
européenne le contrôle qu'elle exerce
sur ce diaspora notamment par des entre
guillemets postes de police chinois
distribué à travers l'Union européenne
dont on connaît l'importance qu'elle
accorde à la coopération universitaire
et scientifique dans des conditions qui
ne sont pas toujours transparentes et
dans des conditions qui imposent un
récit du régime chinois à certains
universitaires
européens qui en quelque sorte s'y
frotent au travers des Instituts
Confucius notamment on sait aussi que
des scientifiques internationaux se
rendent en Chine au travers d'un
programme qui n'est pas transparent qui
est le programme 1000 talent et qui
permet à la Chine de bénéficier de
connaissances technologiques
occidentales y compris sur des sujets
extrêmement sensibles mais quelque chose
à fait basculer la Chine dans je dirais
une approche différente et encore plus
ingérrante
sans doute deux éléments à la fois la
pandémie du covid et la guerre en
Ukraine on voit maintenant la Chine
reprendre à la fois les recettes et les
thèses de la Russie les recettes si on
voit par exemple la manipulation de
l'information autour de l'origine du
covid on a vu des médias officiels
chinois mais aussi des trolls chinois
mais aussi des diplomates chinois
prétendre que le virus du covid aurait
été inventé dans un laboratoire
militaire américain
fordetric même laboratoire militaire qui
avait été utilisé pour une fausse
information russe sur le sida il y a des
décennies on en est au tout début donc
au tout début la Chine copie sans
forcément beaucoup transformer on voit
aussi
l'usage des cyberattaques la Russie est
de loin le pays qui en commet le plus
mais la Chine est venue si je tire en
faire autant et il devient parfois
difficile de faire le distinguo entre
cyberatta Cruz et chinois je pense en
particulier à celle au pluriel qui ont
ciblé l'agent européenne du médicament
au moment où les dossiers des
laboratoires Pfizer moderna était entre
les mains de l'agence européenne et ou
des cyberattaques ont sans doute vu
travailler ensemble espions chinois et à
cœur russe
on voit aussi des thèses
russes reprises par la Chine beaucoup
autour de la guerre du crâne sur tous
les médias sociaux chinois on retrouve
le narratif russe et un narratif
clairement antioxydantal là encore une
note interne de l'administration
chinoise qui a été communiquée par un
lanceur d'alerte qui justifie de cibler
les démocratie constitutionnelle
occidentale une fois de plus je dirais
CDI
d'autres pays ciblent l'Union européenne
depuis longtemps et encore maintenant je
pense à l'Azerbaïdjan on se souvient du
caviarget qui avait frappé l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe on
constate aujourd'hui une chasse au
dissidents qui se mène parfois sur notre
propre territoire et je dirais en tout
cas c'est mon avis personnel au déni
notre propre souveraineté quand
quelqu'un qui a reçu le statut de
réfugiés politiques et confronté à des
tentatives d'assassinat sur notre sol et
cette arrivée
je parlerai aussi
des mouvements religieux qui au travers
de certains pays ou en mouvement
nonétatique interfèrent avec l'Union
européenne je pense d'abord au mouvement
islamiste et au pays qui soutiennent en
particulier les Frères musulmans dans
toute la largesse la largeur de cette
composante ça peut être la Turquie ça
peut être le
Qatar au niveau des institutions
européennes on voit par exemple un
organisme comme le fait-misso qui
s'adresse aux jeunesse et aux étudiants
musulmans d'Europe être
bien qu'il le nie très lié aux Frères
musulmans et
sans arrêt en train de
s'exprimer auprès des institutions
européennes et de bénéficier de
financement de la Commission européenne
sur lesquelles il y a à se pencher ce
que j'ai commencé à faire pour pas
seulement dénoncer parce que ça c'est
facile mais aussi décider avec la
Commission européenne quels critères
permettent de nous protéger de ce type
d'interférences
cathare lui aussi soutient les Frères
musulmans c'est une évidence on l'a vu
au Parlement européen
semble-t-il puisque l'enquête est en
cours et que la présomption d'innocence
étant ce qu'elle est je prends les
précautions qui vont avec et il
semblerait qu'il y ait une tentative de
corruption ou une corruption de membres
ou d'anciens membres du Parlement
européen c'est d'ailleurs là-dessus que
je rédige le rapport pour la commission
1g2 qui sera voté au mois de juin puis
au mois de juillet
mais aussi des mouvements religieux
chrétiens étrangers qui tentent de
s'ingérer dans
les institutions européennes ou dans
l'Union européenne très largement des
mouvements au stylo droit des femmes des
mouvements hostiles au LGBT souvent
inspiré à la fois d'évangéliques
américains d'orthodoxe russe
on retrouve parfois côte à côte des
Polonais des Russes autour de Constantin
malof et des Américains dans la même
conférence ce qui est un peu vertigineux
ils sont au moins d'accord sur une chose
c'est pour si je retire en faire baser
ou faire et aux minor
et de l'argent et notamment de l'argent
russe circule dans ces mouvements et
donc il est naturel de s'interroger sur
les Frères musulmans et sur des
ingérences extérieures islamistes mais
n'oublions jamais que ce ne sont pas les
seuls et que les inclus les autres
d'ailleurs s'en prennent au droit des
femmes vous n'aurez pas étonné que pour
ma part cette dimension-là me touche
alors en France est-ce que nous sommes
différents des autres il y a peu de
raisons de le penser le caractère
cible privilégié de l'ingérence russe je
crois mérite d'être relayé reprenant les
campagnes électorales celles de 2017
l'abondance de trolls russes dans la
campagne présent pour cliver les débats
jamais pour dire que la Russie est un
pays magnifique mais toujours pour
essayer de s'introduire dans des débats
français et d'essayer de les en venir
mais en quelque sorte
le rôle d'entreprise d'État dite
d'informations mais d'entreprises d'État
russe de propagande qui dénigre syst
automatiquement le même candidat
Emmanuel Macron je ne citerai pas toutes
les
qualitifsificatifs fleuries dont il a
fait l'objet de ces entreprises mais je
peux aussi vous le souhaitez le lien
entre troll russe et militant de ce
qu'on appelle l'altright américaine le
même qu'on a vu en 2016 au moment de de
l'élection présidentielle américaine on
le revoit pour
tenter de discréditer Emmanuel Macron
pour mettre en avant des défauts rumeurs
je pense par exemple au compte bancaire
d'Emmanuel Macron Bahamas on voit la
circulation entre troll russe altraite
américaine et malheureusement la reprise
par une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle en France
le piratage de la campagne d'Emmanuel
Macron alors il n'est pas strictement
attribué
il est caractérisé comme donc semblable
au méthodes employées par
le groupe de hacker russe fan cyber on
voit là encore le contenu par d'abord
chez des militants américains pour
revenir ensuite amplifier par des bottes
en France sans succès puisque les
institutions ont réagi avec son froid et
l'opération si j'ose dire a échoué et je
rappelle la confidence publique
enregistrée dans une émission de
télévision d'un troll russe assez
célèbre qui s'appelle Constantin ricov
et qui dit nous avons réussi Trump et
président malheureusement marine n'est
pas devenue présidente une opération a
réussi l'autre à échouer face caméra
le canal privilégié par Moscou pour
diffuser son influence en France et
comme ailleurs en Europe l'extrême
droite privilégiée pas le seul
privilégier tout de même alors la Russie
et le RN c'est une histoire qui commence
avec Jean-Marie Le Pen et qu'il se
poursuit de nombreux voyages
systématique vraiment fréquent des
déclarations
inhabituelles par leur nombre par leur
intensité sur
l'appréciation portée vis-à-vis de
Vladimir Poutine je n'imaginais aucune
de ces déclarations prononcée par aucun
autre homme ou femme politique
s'agissant d'un autre dirigeant
politique étranger c'est ça qui frappe
quand on dit j'admire Vladimir Poutine
quand on dit
la prise de position est plus libre en
Russie qu'en France je n'imagine aucun
politique
cité un pays étranger et dire la même
chose d'un dirigeant étranger et ça se
reproduit de manière
récurrente y compris à chaque fois que
la Russie est mise en cause assassinat
de Boris namsov empoisonnement de des
deux scripts au Royaume-Uni à chaque
fois on entend du RN des arguments que
ne démentirait pas un porte-parole russe
y compris au début de la guerre
d'Ukraine puisque on entend une mise en
doute des crimes de guerre on entend une
un narratif expliquant que l'OTAN à sa
part de responsabilité
une opposition aux livraison d'armes et
en position aux sanctions à la Russie
tout ça finit par faire je dirais une
grille de lecture
qui peut être totalement celle de
quelqu'un qui pense sincèrement que la
Russie est attaquée
et que les torts sont partagés ce qui
est naturellement plus troublant et plus
rare c'est la question du financement du
rassemblement national au travers
d'abord d'une banque russe
seule partie à avoir eu recours à une
banque russe et pas n'importe laquelle
puisque cette banque est connue pour
avoir participé à du blanchiment
d'argent de la corruption et au
contournement de sanctions iraniennes et
puis cette banque ayant fait faillite le
prêt a été repris là encore non pas par
n'importe quelle banque ou n'importe
quel entreprise mais par une entreprise
russe sous sanction américaine pour
[Musique]
participation à la prolifération d'armes
de destruction massive sachant que cette
entreprise qui exporte des pièces
détachées aéronautiques
le fait notamment en
direction de la Syrie de Bachar el-Assad
donc des choix
très particulier et
qui reste aujourd'hui
je dirais
l'exception celle du rassemblement
national 2022 maintenant qu'il est
interdit de rechercher des financements
en dehors de l'Union Européenne le
rassemblement national empreinte en
Hongrie dans une banque hongroise proche
de Victor van donc le dirigeant européen
qui a le plus de sympathie pour la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine cela
interroge en tout cas ce sont des choix
qui n'ont pas été faits par aucun autre
parti politique quel qu'il soit quel que
soit son positionnement sa taille ou ses
résultats électoraux au-delà des
déclarations de Marine Le Pen il y a
celle de nombreuses autres membres du
rassemblement national qui sont très
fréquemment pas toujours mais très
fréquemment
sensible au narratif russe
le rassemblement national n'est pas le
seul à apprécier la Russie on le voit
beaucoup dans le parti reconquête avec
là encore un mélange de déclaration
et de voyage
y compris de voyages d'affaires quand il
s'agit de Philippe de Villiers de sa
tentative de monter un puit du chou en
Crimée annexé par la Russie là encore
c'est un choix qui lui revient
mais qui n'est pas large et qui n'est
pas habituelle
je dirais aussi que s'agissant des votes
de l'extrême droite il y a ceux que l'on
constate ici en France il y a ce que
l'on constate toujours en France mais à
Strasbourg au Parlement européen et il
peut y avoir une certaine forme de
différence dans la manière dont
l'extrême droite se positionne sur les
questions liées à la Russie je ne
manquerai pas
de relever des choix de positionnement
de LFI sur la Russie sur l'Ukraine
très teinté d'anti-américanisme c'est
clair de l'hostilité à l'OTAN c'est
clair mais aussi on verra on relèvera
que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a longtemps été
conseillée par deux personnes
la sympathie pour la Russie était
manifeste et qui sont qui ont l'une et
l'autre quitté LFI l'un pour monter un
parti souverainiste et l'autre pour
rejoindre le rassemblement national
évidemment pour avoir parlé de parlerai
mais brièvement de François Fillon et du
fait que il est tout de même étrange que
deux anciens chefs de gouvernement et
réjouir des intérêts économiques russes
proches du Kremlin
je voudrais rapidement donner un coup de
projecteur sur d'autres formes
d'ingérence de la Russie dans notre pays
l'utilisation de relais médiatique qui
en quelque sorte n'a fait que croître
depuis que le Châteaudun et spundy ont
été fermés en Europe d'autres relais ont
pris la suite et on se souvient par
exemple du
présentateur de la chaîne Youtube
thinkerview qui se veut disruptif gérant
l'actualité autrement
et qui a été invité par sa galère Rohff
quand il lavrose est venu à Paris qui a
accepté l'invitation et qui invite
régulièrement des officiels russes dans
son émission là encore c'est son droit
nous sommes dans un pays de liberté et
c'est notre chance mais c'est aussi son
choix mais c'est un choix qui qui peut
interroger je parlais de sujets clivant
dans lesquels les médias russes ou
prorus ou les trolls se sont beaucoup
investis en France c'est le cas de des
gilets jaunes c'est le cas de la
pandémie de covid je citerai aussi une
création plus récente de
Prigogine il a appelé la FBI pour
rappeler que lui-même est recherché pour
le FBI la foundation to battle Angels
qui veut défendre des lanceurs d'alerte
ou des victimes de violences policières
je mets quelques guillemets aux uns et
aux autres mais en tout cas qui lui
donne des moyens de visibilité des
moyens financiers et des moyens
juridiques il y a fort à parier que sur
ces sujets là comme sur d'autres le but
c'est de cliver et c'est d'obtenir que
les Français se dressent les uns contre
les autres évidemment un mot sur les
campagnes anti-françaises menées en
Afrique par la Russie
avec les deux jambes de Jeff Kenny
Picotine d'un côté le groupe Wagner mais
de l'autre toutes son groupe de médias
de désinformation y compris en
manipulant des influenceurs
panafricanistes
pour essayer de dresser les opinions
publiques africaines contre la France
j'avais parlé de la Turquie sur l'Europe
la Turquie est active en France elle est
en grand en guerre contre la laïcité à
la française on l'a vu en particulier
après l'assassinat de Samuel Paty on a
vu des déclarations du président turc
mais on a aussi vu le président turc en
2018 dire que les musulmans de France
étaient sous sa protection je considère
à titre personnel qu'il s'agit
clairement d'une ingérence on voit ces
ingérences passées au travers d'imam
détachées c'est le plus gros fournisseur
d'imam détaché en France au travers
d'associations qui sont proches du parti
au pouvoir et qui soit essayé de
présenter des candidats à des élections
locales soit essaye ou soit gère très
simplement des mosquées en France
minigorus gère 70 mosquées en France
aujourd'hui
je conclurai avant de répondre à vos
questions en disant que d'une certaine
manière
ces activisme de certains régimes à
notre endroit
vise à nous rendre soit hystériques soit
apathique hystérique c'est à dire nous
dresser les uns contre les autres et
nous donner l'impression que quel que
soit le sujet tout va devenir violente
tout tout va devenir irrégonciliable
soit apathique c'est lorsque la
désinformation vient toucher des sujets
notamment des sujets internationaux sur
lesquels
l'objectif c'est de faire en sorte que
les opinions
occidentales renoncent à avoir un avis
en vienne à se dire finalement je ne
sais pas c'est beaucoup le cas sur
l'Ukraine donc quand on nie l'existence
de crime de guerre à bout de chat quand
on est la présence de civile dans le
théâtre de Mario Paul ça n'est pas
vraiment fait pour être cru ça c'est une
vieille habitude russe la vraniose n’est
pas fait pour être cru c'est frais à la
fois pour intimider et pour que à la fin
un certain nombre de gens se détournent
du sujet en disant on n'y comprend rien
et donc on va laisser faire parce que
c'est trop compliqué et je voudrais
terminer si vous le MI autorisez parce
que je sais que j'étais un peu longue
par une citation d'Anna à Rennes qui me
que je relis régulièrement dans mon
travail un peuple qui ne peut plus rien
croire ne peut se faire une opinion il
est privé non seulement de sa capacité
d'agir mais aussi de sa capacité de
penser et de juger et avec un tel peuple
vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez et
ça me paraît malheureusement
prémonitoire par rapport aux ingérences
dont nous sommes la cible aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup madame la ministre non
vous avez tout le temps nécessaire
puisque la règle que nous sommes fixés
en tout cas qui est fixée pour la
présidence cette commission c'est que
les propos préliminaires doivent
éclairer la représentation nationale et
tant que le propos ne tourne pas en rond
ne fait pas trop tendance je n'ai aucune
raison de le de l'arrêter ou de le
diminuer et vous n'avez absolument pas
fait de regroupement si vous avez avancé
dans votre raisonnement et dans votre
exposé sans du tout tournant en rond et
en apportant à chacun de vos propos des
informations différentes de celles que
vous aviez dit avant donc vous n'avez
pas du tout débordé le temps ou en tout
cas de la façon dont nous travaillons
dans cette commission je vous remercie
d'ailleurs aussi d'avoir conclu votre
propos par cette citation d'Anna rent
que je pense nous pouvons reprendre
collectivement en tant que reprennent
représentant de la nation et vous l'avez
d'ailleurs en introduction de de votre
propos l'objet de cette commission
d'enquête que le rassemblement national
a proposé et que qui a été validé par la
commission des lois justement d'apporter
sa pierre modeste sa contribution
modeste à identification
des tentatives ou des réalités
d'ingérence de toutes formes vous l'avez
dit en particulier vous avez raison vous
l'avez bien résumé d'ailleurs
effectivement sous une forme de
corruption des élites ou d'influence des
élites en tout cas toutes les personnes
ou toutes les institutions qui sont
susceptibles d'avoir de comment dire de
l'influence sur nos compatriotes ou sur
les processus de décision et là-dessus
nous sommes parfaitement d'accord
j'espère sans aucune prétention que ces
travaux permettront d'apporter une
pierre à l'édifice commune au niveau
français et européen
ma première question madame la ministre
c'est que ce soit dans l'exposé que vous
avez fait ou dans les travaux que vous
avez mené vous menez encore vous avez
fait une comparaison que je trouve très
intéressante et c'est la première fois
qu'elle a été faite vraiment une
typologie des différentes formes
d'ingérences que relevées depuis vous
avez commencé se faire de ma part au
brexit et j'ai l'impression que c'était
à la fois géographiquement un
temporellement à s'organiser
vous avez cité des phénomènes massifs
notamment sur l'enquête qui a été menée
aux États-Unis
pour ce qui est et il voulait savoir si
vous pouvez établir un aimant de
comparaison avec la France puisque alors
c'est compliqué parce qu'il y en a une
partie qui a été réalisée sous huis clos
mais les comptes-rendus d'ailleurs à
notre surprise les comptes rendus ont
été publiés donc sont consultables pour
ce qui est cette auditions pour ce qui
est de ces auditions mais validé par les
personnes c'est dans le droit pochette
commissaire dans le respect du droit et
de la pratique et de l'usage mais sans
mentionner les personnes qui nous ont
indiqué cela
Christine que les faits d'ingérence
notamment dans les derniers processus
électoraux français même si les existent
on semble-t-il pour ce qui est de le cas
d'espèces de la France était
comment dire contrôlé par nos services
de renseignement mais aussi par nos
règles démocratiques qui nous sont
propres par exemple les différences de
financement entre la France évidemment
les États-Unis où là on est c'est le
c'est le jour et la nuit je pense qu'on
pouvait tous être d'accord sur sur la
situation en français et américaine sur
les règles de financement aussi bien sur
les montants mis en jeu dans le dans nos
campagnes que sur leur encadrement donc
voilà ma question c'est est-ce que à
l'éclairage de votre expérience de
l'exposé que vous avez fait de vos
travaux vous pouvez comparer et éclairer
les commissaires sur la situation
française est-ce qu'elle vous semble
sous contrôle danger est-ce qu'il y a
des progrès qui ont été faits est-ce que
vous avez mentionné 2017-2022 donc on
peut comparer voilà
alors il faut toujours parler
de ce qu'on sait vraiment et tout n'est
pas documenté où tout n'est pas regroupé
à chaque fois que j'ai écrit quelque
chose dans mon livre ou que j'ai dit
quelque chose devant vous c'est parce
que les sources qu'il avait mis à jour
avait été considéré comme fiable et on
fait l'objet d'aucune contestation ou
lorsque contestation il y a eu elles ont
eu gain de cause donc il faut toujours
parler avec
prudence et ne pas penser que l'on
connaît l'entièreté d'une ingérence
passée ou d'une situation présente il
est
manifeste que 2016 a constitué pour
l'élection américaine je dirais un pic
et que 2020 a vu se mettre en place des
mesures de
prudence et de contrôle de l'intégrité
européenne élect pardon beaucoup plus
grande aux États-Unis qui ont fait
d'ailleurs que ceux qui voulaient croire
ou faire croire à des ingérences en
principe chinoise dans l'élection de Joe
Biden ce sont cassés les dents
ils se sont cassés les dents mais ça n'a
pas empêché
un mouvement qu'on a appelé stop de
style une contestation des résultats des
des élections par une frange très dure
de l'électorat de Donald Trump qui s'est
quand même traduit par la saut du
Capitole du 6 janvier donc une élection
beaucoup moins exposée mais quelque
chose comme un poison qui avait été
instillé dans la confiance dans les
institutions poison qui continue à faire
son chemin et je nous encourage à être
conscient de ça c'est à dire ne jamais
s'endormir sur nos lauriers ne jamais se
dire bon ben puisqu'on passe le cap et
que on est plus vigilant plus conscient
plus plus en alerte
se porte mieux le poison du soupçon et
quelque chose qui peut continuer à faire
mal des années plus tard quand le
soupçon
concerne les institutions en général les
médias également et que finalement on
finit par nos plus croire à rien et à
croire n'importe quoi en même temps
s'agissant des ingérences dans la
campagne de 2017
ce que disent les experts les
entreprises de
surveillance des réseaux sociaux
notamment c'est que les attaques étaient
toutes dirigées contre un candidat et un
seul Emmanuel Macron que
elles sont passées notamment par des
faux comptes Facebook très nombreux qui
ont conduit à l'époque Facebook allait
déceler et aller fermer
la question comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure des des Macron lixes comme on
les a appelé donc de ce hacking de
contenu comme dans le cas américain
mélange de contenu exact et de contenu
inventé des changes entre membres de la
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas eu
d'impact parce qu'il y a eu un réflexe
démocratique comme vous le disiez
monsieur le Président d'un certain
nombre d'institutions et d'autorités
indépendante qui ont tout de suite
compris que le risque était de porter
atteinte à l'intégrité du processus
électoral et les médias professionnels
ont aussi eu ce réflexe de ne pas tomber
dans le piège c'est à la fois une
satisfaction et une fragilité ça repose
en réalité sur le comportement des
hommes
plus que sur la solidité je dirais du
système pour éviter ce type de
manipulation parce que il s'agit de
manipulation sur 2022 on voit un peu
comme en Allemagne
la manipulation passe moins par des
sujets purement politiques au sens
propre que par
la l'amplification de sujets de société
on a vu les mêmes choix fait un peu de
la même façon en particulier sur la
question autour de la politique de covid
et la politique vaccinale considérée je
dirais comme des bons sujets
qui permettent de cliver qui permettent
de porter atteinte à la confiance dans
les institutions et là on voit à nouveau
des amplifications de contenu des
réseaux sociaux le contenu il est
généralement national au départ mais sa
visibilité son amplification et
encourager par des acteurs extérieurs à
commencer par la Russie qui reste depuis
2009 dans cette logique de ne plus
essayer de se promouvoir elle-même mais
de discréditer les pays européens
occidentaux et les démocraties c'est ce
que ce que l'on peut en dire aujourd'hui
peut-être juste un mot sur 2017 pour
illustrer ce que je disais sur cette
volonté de de clivage
les experts qui ont étudié les mots
employés par des trolls russes dans leur
contenu pour essayer de mesurer les mots
qui devenait le plus souvent ces mots
sont noirs féminisme gay vert arabes
Islam extrême droite gauche droite
ce sont ces mots qu'on retrouve le plus
souvent dans des contenus de troll russe
identifié comme venant de de la galaxie
de gagner prigogi après vous mettez ce
que vous voulez autour mais ce sont les
contenus qui sont censés déclencher une
réponse et monter en visibilité
merci beaucoup madame la ministre madame
ma deuxième question avant de faire
tourner la parole parce que je veux pas
énormément de questions suite à vos
propos mais je veux que la parole tourne
et puis si nous avons le temps et à
l'occasion et cette question pas posées
je reviendrai dans un deuxième temps
mais je ne veux pas une fois plus
monopoliser la parole
lorsque vous étiez ministre des affaires
européennes puis candidate le
différencie tout à fait les deux sans
aucune sans aucune autre attention que
différencier les deux vous savez qu'il y
a plus avoir et je sais pas totalement
cet enjeu de l'enjeu beaucoup plus grave
de l'intérence russe ou chinoise ou une
veste de de comment dire de puissance
autoritaire tyrannique ou hostile et
hostile
une confrontation entre la pratique
française notamment du financement des
campagnes électorales et de
l'intervention par des fondations par
exemple d'entreprises privées
qui est totalement interdite en France
et qui est autorisé au niveau européen
je me souviens ce qu'on avait eu des
entretiens vous avez eu la gentillesse
de nous recevoir pour préparer les
élections c'était déjà un sujet je me
souviens que c'est un sujet qui vous
interpellait je dis sans aucune flatrice
de qui vous concernait puisque
évidemment ça va contre les règles le
françaises malheureusement aucune
solution n'avait été trouvée à l'époque
mais c'est pas de la faute de la France
on sait comment fonctionne les
institutions européennes
là les élections de nouvelles élections
européennes arrivent est-ce que vous
estimez que la situation a changé ou
qu'il y a toujours un risque de alors on
va dire d'influence de de par des
fondations
d'intérêt privé évidemment c'est pas de
même nature mais comme vous êtes là
personne qu'on a reçu laquelle plus
concerné directement par ce sujet par
votre expérience je me permets de vous
la poser maintenant avant de faire
tourner la parole
alors merci d'avoir appelé
qu'effectivement nous avions échangé sur
ce sujet et qu'effectivement c'est une
culture qui est très éloignée de la
culture française et que en l'occurrence
je me sens très française
c'est d'ailleurs la raison enfin je
tiens à préciser que il rejoint le
groupe politique l'Union
aujourd'hui
un groupe politique ne peut pas recevoir
de financement de d'entreprises privées
ça peut être le cas d'un parti politique
européen mais ça ne peut pas être le cas
d'un groupe politique et le parti
politique auquel j'appartiens le parti
horizon aujourd'hui
n'appartient à aucun groupe politique
européen à partir en groupe politique
dans l'Union européenne n'a aucun parti
politique européen est né donc pas
concerné par cette cette différence de
culture je crois que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et qui va dans le bon sens
c'est l'accroissement de la transparence
et en matière d'ingérence vous avez
raison ce sont deux choses très
différentes là j'allais dire l'ingérence
des lobbies ou l'ingérence de puissance
étrangère malveillante on parle de deux
choses malgré tout très différentes ça
n'empêche pas que l'ingérence de lobby
soit un sujet en soi et lutter contre
cette ingérence passe d'abord par la
transparence c'est-à-dire si vous
recevez un financement de quel montant
et d'où vient-il le danger des
ingérences
de pays étrangers malveillants c'est
qu'il est souvent souterrain clandestin
illégal en ce qui concerne le
financement d'un parti politique en
France aujourd'hui mais que
ce n'est pas parce que un comportement
est illégal que malheureusement il n'a
pas lieu le catarget nous prouve si
les personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
incarcérées sont finalement condamnés
que un comportement illégal a pu avoir
lieu de leur part comme de la part du
pays qui aurait réussi à les corrompre
c'est la transparence qui en matière de
d'entreprises privées
peut conduire les électeurs à savoir
très précisément je dirais à qui il
s'adresse
mais je ne dirais pas que ce modèle soit
celui qui a ma préférence de loin
je vous remercie madame la rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
la Ministre cher Nathalie Loiseau pour
cette présentation extrêmement précise
extrêmement argumenté et qui interpelle
forcément qui interpelle les députés de
la République que nous sommes mais
également toutes celles et tous ceux qui
qui nous suivent qui s'intéressent à nos
travaux maintenant ou qui le feront un
peu plus tard qui regarderont la vidéo
ou liront le compte rendu de votre
audition et peut-être même le rapport
lorsque rapport il y aura de cette
commission d'enquête j'en pouvais juste
pour dire que cette commission d'enquête
est assez regardée semblerait-il ce
n'est pas la première fois que la
représentation nationale se penche sur
le sujet des ingérences étrangères il y
a eu un an et demi et deux ans
maintenant je crois un rapport
d'information très intéressant fait par
nos collègues sénateurs André gatelin
Étienne blanc très ciblés c'est vrai sur
les ingérences chinois c'est pas tout à
fait comme ça que c'est le rapport
d'information mais c'est ça que ça
revenait dans les milieux universitaires
de recherche les milieux académiques et
New York vont d'ailleurs auditionné
André gatelin à cet égard il y a
quelques semaines et par ailleurs depuis
l'automne la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement donc sa structure interne
qui réunit 4 sénateurs et 4 députés dont
j'ai l'honneur de l'une d'Elvis
présidente et qui est présidée par Sacha
Ollier a décidé de consacrer son rapport
annuel au thème des ingérences
étrangères certes elles sont parentaire
enseignement travail de manière beaucoup
plus confidentielle que notre commission
d'enquête et elle a un temps un peu plus
long puisque nous avons un peu moins
d'un an pour ce rapport voilà tout ça
pour transmettre également l'information
à ceux qui qui nous qui nous écoutent
et justement tous ceux qui nous écoutent
et qui s'intéressent au sujet des
intérêts étrangères comme l'a dit le
présentant Guy peuvent vraiment très
utilement se rapporter à votre ouvrage
la guerre qu'on ne voit pas venir qui
est une somme je le dis très franchement
absolument passionnante sur le sujet qui
nous intéresse c'est qui très largement
je dirais et géographiquement et et en
matière de méthode de stratégie et de
modalités fait un tableau qui me semble
être extrêmement complet et de ce fait
assez inquiétant bien évidemment assez
inquiétant cette guerre qu'on ne voit
pas venir mais alors justement dans
votre ouvrage vous avez parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé de manipulation
d'informations des informations fake
news mal information les stratégies
d'interférence à travers les moyens
technologiques et leur donnent
évidemment une puissance absolument
inégalée et le savoir-faire qui s'est
progressivement développé
dans la sphère russe qui mène donc une
guerre internationale qu'on ne pouvait
pas ignorer tout avait toujours été très
clairement dit y compris des années des
années voire des décennies mais
également de la part de la Chine de la
part de la Turquie qu'on a vu à l'œuvre
par exemple
contre
la France après un tragique
assassinat mais vous avez également dans
votre ouvrage
choisi de consacrer un chapitre que vous
intitulé les idiots utiles sont parmi
nous a donc un centre de personnalité et
là aussi tout est assez documenté j'ai
cru comprendre que vous n'aviez pas été
attaqué pour diffamation par qui que ce
soit et donc j'aimerais bien que vous
n'en disiez peut-être un peu plus sur
certaines des
personnalités que vous avez
qualifié entre guillemets d'idiot utile
qui sont déjà parmi nous
merci merci de vos paroles aimables sur
ce livre que j'ai fait après avoir
effectivement beaucoup travaillé sur le
sujet compte tenu de ce que j'avais pu
apprendre je n'avais pas envie de le
dire de le garder pour moi
alors l'expression du utile comme vous
le savez est une expression qui n'est
pas de moi qui est une expression que
l'on prête à Lénine même si elle est
peut-être en quelque sorte apocryphe
mais en tout cas qui désigne des
personnes qui sans être eux-mêmes
proches sur le plan idéologique de de
pays autoritaires en sont les relais
c'est peu dire que la France est en
quelque sorte une espèce d'exception
culturelle s'agissant de la Russie
je le dis en tant que parlementaire
européenne
pour être
non pas prise à partie mais interroger
très souvent par des collègues européens
qui ont du mal à comprendre
ce que qualifie de complaisance de
beaucoup de
politiques d'intellectuel
français
vis-à-vis non pas du pays de la Russie
mais de du régime de Vladimir Poutine
que la France est une vieille histoire
avec la Russie c'est une évidence
qui est une appréciation forte de la
culture russe en France aussi qui est
une présence intellectuelle d'une
diaspora arrivée dès 1917 aussi c'est un
peu une particularité française et c'est
une belle particularité
qu'il y ait eu des résistants
communistes pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale et un parti communiste fort en
1945 c'est aussi ça fait partie de notre
histoire
là où c'est plus difficile à comprendre
c'est lorsque cela conduit à fermer les
yeux sur la réalité d'un régime
politique et on a vu un parti communiste
en France particulièrement bienveillant
vis-à-vis des crimes de Staline on s'en
souvient on entend encore récemment
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dire que les
communistes n'ont pas de sens sur les
mains pardon mais cet assemblée à voter
récemment au sujet de Lolo de mort s'il
y a bien un crime qui est aujourd'hui
qualifié de génocide ou Staline a du
sens sur les mains c'est notamment
celui-là et c'est loin d'être le seul
c'est tout aussi troublant à chaque fois
que l'on entend dans la bouche soit de
responsable politique soit
d'intellectuel que par exemple la
liberté d'expression serait plus grande
en Russie qu'en France
et je l'ai dit dans mon propos
introductif on l'a entendu dans la
bouche de Marine Le Pen on l'a entendu
dans la bouche d'Eric Zemmour
on peut aimer la Russie sans être obligé
de dire ça
surtout quand
Anna polytop skaya a déjà été assassiné
on ne peut plus plaider l'ignorance
ça veut dire que on ferme sciemment les
yeux et là c'est une une vraie
préoccupation
entendre dire que
la Dima Poutine est un démocrate un
démocrate autoritaire comme l'avait dit
Éric Zemmour pendant cela sa campagne
pour la présidentielle à un moment où on
sait à quoi ressemble les élections en
Russie un moment ou Alexa valny est
empoisonné et emprisonné
ou Boris namsov a été assassiné là
encore
même la sympathie
ne suffit pas à expliquer
cette complaisance
vis-à-vis d'un régime dont
sur lequel les informations sont
disponibles quand mémorial a pendant des
années documenté les violations des
droits de l'homme à la fois sous Staline
mais aussi récente quand une membre de
mémorial a été assassinée qu'en mémorial
a été fermé par les autorités russes on
ne peut pas à ce moment-là fermer les
yeux et pourtant on lit des déclarations
qui ne peuvent que troubler
lorsque
j'hésite à parce qu'elles sont si
nombreuses que que j'allais dire je ne
sais pas quoi choisir mais quand Marine
Le Pen après l'assassinat de Boris namso
répond j'ai confiance dans la justice
russe
contenue de ce qu'est l'injustice russe
on ne peut qu'être troublé qu'est-ce qui
empêche Madame Le Pen à ce moment de
dire
sa préoccupation
sur l'assassinat d'un opposant sans
aller plus loin si elle ne souhaite pas
aller plus loin mais quand le père et la
fille scientales sont
empoisonnés pourquoi Marine Le Pen
dit-elle exclusivement que l'Union
européenne mène une guerre froide à la
Russie
pourquoi
c'est pas l'Union européenne qui
empoisonne de personnes c'est l'Union
européenne qui s'inquiètent que des
armes chimiques soient utilisées sur son
sol puisqu'à l'époque le Royaume-Uni est
encore dans l'Union européenne je peux
en dire autant comme j'ai commencé à le
faire d'autres déclarations d'autres
personnes vous avez reçu Thierry Mariani
vous l'avez entendu je ne reviendrai pas
sur ses choix qui lui reviennent mais
qui sont de nature extrêmement
particulière là encore on peut
avoir des raisons personnelles d'aimer
la Russie et
c'est parfaitement acceptable et et
personne n'a à y redire de la participer
à des opérations dites d'observation
électorale
sur des scrutins
aucun partenaire international sérieux
n'envoie d'observateurs
dans des voyages où l'on est payé
par des interlocuteurs du pays où se
déroule de scrutin pour s'y rendre et
pas seulement en allant tout seul pas
seulement Thierry Mariani mais quand il
s'est rendu
pour observer le scrutin sur le
changement de Constitution il choisit
d'aller en Crimée annexée
sachant que la communauté internationale
ne reconnaît pas l'annexion russe de la
Crimée et en tout ce sont 10 députés du
rassemblement national qui qui se
déplace
c'est un choix c'est un choix qui tout
de même interroge parce que ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il rend service au
narratif du régime de Vladimir Poutine
et que les médias russes relayent la
présence de 10 députés du rassemblement
national dans cette opération électorale
contestée par ailleurs et l'une des
membres de cette de ce déplacement
aujourd'hui vice-président de
l'Assemblée nationale et la porte parle
de modèles de démocratie quand on sait
la manière dont s'est déroulée ce
scrutin
on peut avoir de la sympathie pour un
pays sans nier les évidences c'est là où
je parle de
j'allais dire de d'idiot utile je
reviens aussi sur le covid parce que
c'est un moment je dirais assez
fondateurs
s'agissant d'ingérence parce que on est
dans l'ingérence qui n'est pas
directement politique qui j'allais dire
est directement sociétal à destination
des individus vous souvenez de toutes
les innombrables polémiques autour de la
politique de santé de notre pays
je ne sais pas si on ne se souvient bien
de ceux qui
pressaient la France
d'utiliser le vaccin russe
c'était le cas de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'était le cas de Jordan Bardella qui
regrettait qu'on s'interdise d'utiliser
le vaccin Sputnik fait par idéologie ou
par russophobie je précise que jamais le
laboratoire qui produit
n'a donné un dossier complet à l'Agence
européenne du médicament
et c'est la raison très simple très
factuelle et très compréhensive qui a
fait que jamais ce vaccin qui par
ailleurs a suscité la défiance en Russie
même mais que jamais ce vaccin n'a pu
être autorisé c'est que les essais
cliniques n'ont jamais été complètement
communiqués à l'Agence européenne du
médicament il n'y avait donc aucune
idéologie aucune russophobie il y avait
en revanche une désinformation russe sur
le moment même où le dossier avait
commencé à être déposé sur lequel une
opacité araignée on avait beaucoup de
mal nous-mêmes parlementaire européen à
savoir quand on écoutait la
communication russe on pensait que le
dossier était déposé quand on appelait
les experts qui sont totalement
apolitiques de l'Agence européenne du
médicament immobilier non non pas du
tout on a on a rien du tout
donc il y avait une entreprise de
désinformation entendre dire que c'était
par idéologie et paruphophobie que le
vaccin n'était pas déjà autorisé était
quand même extrêmement troublant et on
peut aller j'ai cité tout à l'heure
Philippe de Villiers allant essayer de
vendre un Puy du Fou à Vladimir Poutine
je dirais pourquoi pas des hommes
d'affaires qui ont travaillé en Russie
il y en a eu énormément
était-il obligé pour autant
de dire il manque un Vladimir Poutine à
la France je ne suis pas sûr
ou Marion maréchal de dire que Vladimir
Poutine est un partenaire vital
je n'ai là encore j'y reviens et pardon
si je me répète je n'ai jamais entendu
un français d'un quelconque parti
politique
dire
il manque un Joe Biden à la France
jamais
pardon
ah je crois pas qu'il dit ça je pense
qu'il peut il fait des parallèles sur
l'âge qui lui qui qui montre qui montre
une certaine forme du mot mais de là à
dire que l'idéal pour la France ce
serait Joe Biden je ne crois pas l'avoir
entendu dire ça ni quiconque d'ailleurs
et qu'il faudrait une mer qu'elle
française ou j'en sais rien
c'est le il s'agit du seul
personnage politique et quel personnage
politique avant même la guerre du crâne
il y a eu la Géorgie il y a eu la Syrie
il y a eu le don-basse il y a eu les
assassinats et les empoisonnements dont
j'ai parlé choisir d'en faire un modèle
est un choix dont chacun est libre mais
on est aussi libre de s'interroger sur
ce choix
maintenant mais
monsieur ménager c'est une question
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
ministre pour cette exposé et j'ai bien
compris dans la teneur de vos propos
vous étiez attaché à la vérité à lutter
contre l'un des informations vous
permettrez avant de vous poser quelques
questions de réinformer sur un certain
nombre d'éléments que vous avez évoqué
qui sont pour moi des fake news puisque
vous avez écouté ce mot vous avez dit
que Marine Le Pen avait refusé de
dénoncer les crimes de guerre notamment
à bout de chat pourtant quand Joe Biden
traite monsieur Poutine de boucher et de
qualité de criminel de guerre Emmanuel
Macron lui aussi et nous l'avons soutenu
dans ce sens refuse d'utiliser le terme
de criminels de guerre parce qu'il
considère et nous considérons aussi il
ne faut pas humilier la Russie que la
sortie devrait être diplomatique et
c'est vrai que je suis étonné que vous
ayez relié ce genre d'information alors
que c'est la ligne portant d'Emmanuel
Macron que nous avons soutenu et que
nous considérons qu'il y a eu des crimes
de guerre Marine Le Pen la dénoncé et
elle a demandé une enquête
internationale donc ça c'était le
premier point j'ai pas compris vos
propos je vous laisserai bien dans un dû
répondre et me dire
ce que ce que vous pensez et si vous
avez votre votre langue a fourché et si
vous dénoncer par contre ce que monsieur
le Président de la République lui aussi
refuse de de qualifier de criminels de
guerre concernant l'extension de la même
manière j'ai pas compris la ligne est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus complexe c'est-à-dire que nous
avons toujours dénoncé les sanctions qui
étaient néfastes pour les Français mais
toujours soutenu l'ensemble des
sanctions qui elles n'étaient pas
néfastes pour les Français notamment sur
les zodiaque et concernant avant d'aller
sur mes questions le prêt vous avez pas
mentionné le fait que c'était un prêt
tchécos russe un prêt à 6%
6%, ce qui est un taux d'intérêt qui
n'est pas un taux d'amis qui était bien
entendu passer d'une banque nationale
c'était pas de l'argent de Vladimir
Poutine c'était une banque qui en plus a
fait faillite qui prouve bien qu'elle
n'était pas une banque d'État et le tout
contrôlé par la cncfp alors est-ce que
vous remettez en doute et je ne pense
pas en tant que serviteur de l'État vous
êtes nouveau fonctionnaire vous étiez
directrice de Léna vous je vous vois pas
remettre en cause le travail de la
CNCCFP dans ce sens est-ce que vous
considérez de passer une CCFP ne fait
pas bien son travail n'a pas les moyens
de faire son travail et donc en matière
de financement politique est-ce que vous
considérez qu'on a aujourd'hui et ça
c'est ma première question pas les
moyens de vérifier l'ensemble de ces
démons la deuxième question et j'en
aurais d'autres vous évoquez que des
députés présents en crimes en Crimée ont
été payés ils ont eu reçu un salaire une
prestation de service combien leur ont
été versées parce que vous avez dit
le compte rendu ont été payés pour se
rendre en Crimée je l'ai noté alors si
je sais pas si le compte rendu le fera
référence à cela
nous verrons si la vidéo et nous verrons
peut-être que soit votre langue a forgé
soit je n'ai pas bien noté les
informations voilà première question
c'est sur la cncfp je vous laisserai
répondre dans le micro pour infirmer les
propos que je viens d'indiquer et qui
semble-t-il n'est pas les vôtres voilà
et globalement plus globalement vous
dites que le soupçon est un poison et je
suis d'accord ça porte atteinte nous
institutions à la confiance dans les
Français peuvent avoir en la politique
en nos institutions est-ce que vous
considérez aussi que le soupçon peut
être une manière de discréditer des
adversaires politiques c'est la question
que je vous propose plus globalement sur
la sur l'ensemble de vos propos
je vous remercie je relève l'usage que
vous faites du terme réinformation qui
pour moi est à peu près aussi inquiétant
pour moi la réinformation est à
l'information ce que la rééducation est
à l'éducation c'est-à-dire son stricte
contraire la réinformation ça voudrait
dire que l'information qui circule de la
part de journalistes professionnels
mériterait quelque part d'être
reprise en main
vous trouverez toujours chez moi une
défenseur acharnée du journalisme
professionnel et je ne pense pas que
nous ayons besoin de réinformation pas
davantage que de rééducation
ce que j'ai indiqué sur
la position de Madame Le Pen sur les
crimes de guerre au moment où les
atrocités de bout de chat ont été connus
du monde entier
j'en ai un souvenir d'autant plus vif
que je me suis rendu à bout de chat
juste après la libération par les
troupes ukrainiennes et que j'étais
présente au moment où les corps de
victimes étaient déterrés pour que les
familles puissent les identifier
je dois donc reconnaître que dans ce
moment de cette audition je parle avec
une émotion particulière parce que quand
vous avez vécu cela il y a un avant et
il y a un après quand vous avez parlé à
des survivants qui vous disent j'ai eu
de la chance je suis en vie ma femme
aussi il n'y avait que 42 personnes
occupant ma maison mais par chance il y
avait des sous-officiers qui ont
interdit les exactions
dans la rue d'à côté ils n'ont pas eu ma
chance
et quand vous avez sur votre téléphone
portable les vidéos que filmaient les
soldats russes des actions que je
préfère ne pas décrire ici quand elles
sont abominables vidéo pendant
lesquelles se filmaient vous êtes obligé
de parler de bout de chat avec une
certaine émotion
ces informations elles étaient
disponibles très vite il suffisait d'y
aller et lorsque j'y suis allé ça
n'avait rien de particulièrement
héroïque nous étions 30 parlementaires
nationaux et européens à avoir choisi
d'essayer de nous rendre à bout de chat
et à Herpin
celui ou celle qui veut savoir a les
moyens de savoir
à ce moment là j'ai entendu Madame Le
Pen dire on ne sait pas et il faudra une
enquête internationale
je regrette mais bout de chats étaient
occupé par des soldats russes et l'on
savait les témoignages étaient déjà en
train d'être récoltés notamment par des
enquêteurs qui ont été dépêchés par un
certain nombre de pays
étrangers dont notre pays dont c'est
l'honneur de l'avoir fait
que la position de Madame Le Pen est
évoluée entre temps je ne le ni pas en
tout cas que cette déclaration est
évoluée je ne le dis pas je relève qu'il
était possible de dire autre chose que
ce qu'elle a dit au moment où elle l'a
dit
s'agissant des livraisons d'armes j'ai
bien entendu depuis de nombreuses années
le rassemblement national regretté que
François Hollande ne livre pas des
navires de guerre à la Russie après la
déstabilisation du don-basse et
l'annexe de la Crimée j'ai entendu
depuis le début de la guerre Madame Le
Pen choisir de dire que il valait mieux
ne pas participer à l'escalade faire
des distinctions qui là encore quand on
s'est rendu en Ukraine peuvent
interroger je me suis rendu cinq fois en
Ukraine
parce que je préfère ne pas avoir
d'idées préconçues et voir sur place et
juger sur pièce
c'est un choix de Madame Le Pen elle
aurait pu en faire un autre elle a fait
ce choix-là il ne s'agit pas de soupçons
il s'agit de constat
on eux nous sommes libres dans ce pays
de faire nos choix et nous avons aussi
le devoir d'assumer les choix que que
nous faisons je reviens sur le prêt
vous dites c'est une banque elle
s'appelle bon que tchecorus comme BNP
Paribas s'appelle BNP Paribas ça n'est
pas pour autant que c'est encore
aujourd'hui la banque de Paris et des
Pays-Bas et que ça quoi que ce soit
avoir avec
les Pays-Bas ce qui est incontestable
c'est la nature de cette banque le fait
que elle est documentée par les
instances internationales de de
surveillance des activités financières
comme
participant à du blanchiment de
corruption comme participant au
contournement
de sanctions par l'Iran ce n'est donc
pas une banque ordinaire là encore c'est
un choix
c'était légal je ne conteste pas la
légalité de ce choix mais c'est un choix
qui a été fait par le rassemblement
national
on pourra aussi se souvenir de la
chronologie de ce choix avec les
déclarations de Madame Le Pen Madame Le
Pen reconnaissant la validité du
référendum organisé en Crimée après
l'annexion par la Russie et Madame Le
Pen dans la foulée
en printemps auprès d'une banque russe
je ne dis pas que c'est illégal je dis
que c'est particulier
le fait que ce prêt soit repris par une
entreprise qui n'est pas n'importe quel
entreprise mais une entreprise sous
sanction je ne dis pas que c'est illégal
je dis que c'est particulier et je fais
le constat qu'aucun autre parti
politique
en France aucun
n'a fait un choix similaire et je
reprends puisque manifestement nous
sommes mal compris
la question des déplacements de députés
nationaux ou européen du rassemblement
national certains étant passé à
reconquête depuis
dans la rue si de Vladimir Poutine ou
dans la Crimée annexée comme vous le
savez lorsqu'on effectue une mission au
titre du Parlement européen les frais
sont prises en charge par le Parlement
européen ça n'est pas été le cas pour ce
déplacement et se déplacement a été
financé par des partenaires en Russie
qui peuvent être j'ignore lesquels qui
peuvent être des fondations qui peuvent
être des individus là encore c'est un
choix je rappelle d'ailleurs que Thierry
Mariani a été sanctionné au Parlement
européen pour avoir participé à des
opérations dites d'observation
électorale qui n'en était pas vraiment
et avoir laissé planer une ambiguïté sur
le fait qu'il
le faisait en tant que député européen
là encore ce sont des faits cela relève
de choix personnel
qui vont malgré tout dans un sens qui
est toujours le même
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre de vos propos que je note en
réalité extrêmement modérée puisque vous
faites un distinguo que moi-même je fais
entre la singularité de l'extrême droite
et les autres forces politiques de du
spectre politique français
mise à part quelques inexactitudes
concernant Jean-Luc Mélenchon et je me
permets de d'apporter une correction les
communistes n'ont pas de sang sur les
mains et une part évidemment des
communistes français et je crois
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait tort puisque
les communistes avaient du sang sur les
mains c'était du sang nazi
quand à savoir si Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
eu des conseillers pro russe d'abord
Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'a jamais eu de
conseiller pour en quelques domaines que
ce soit il a des interlocuteurs
éventuellement mais pas de conseiller et
les personnes que vous avez mentionnées
l'une d'elles effectivement avait des
missions une activité militante
concernant les relations internationales
mais comme le SAV romain miel carac
lui-même dans le livre qu'il a consacré
aux tentatives d'ingérence de la Russie
a précisé que cette personne avait
elle-même été approchée par la Russie
avait refusé refusé les fonds proposés
par la réussite je ne connais pas
moi-même les éléments de cette histoire
mais en tout cas je me fie au témoignage
et vous travaillez dans quête de
Romainville carré quand à la deuxième
personne mentionnée ces prises de
position concernant la Russie son
postérieur à son départ vers le RN
c'est précisions faites je voudrais vous
poser quelques questions
la première porte sur
sur les entreprises sur le distinguo à
faire entre entreprises et état parler
de lobbying je pense à deux exemples
vous avez travaillé sur la sur le
Royaume-Uni en particulier je sais qu'il
y a une commission d'enquête sur
Cambridge Analytica par exemple le
Royaume-Uni il y a bien sûr la question
de l'affaire Pegasus qui pose aussi de
nombreuses questions j'aimerais savoir
comment vous vous considérez ces
entreprises est-ce que vous considérez
que sont réellement ou potentiellement
les faux nets des états quel genre de
protection nous devrions avoir face à
elle
une deuxième question porte sur
l'attitude qu'on doit avoir vis-à-vis
des états vous avez mentionné toute une
série de tentatives disons d'ingérence
ou de déstabilisation chinoise
le président de la République se trouve
actuellement en Chine
ça pose question dans la mesure où ça
délégation est composée y compris de
Jean-Pierre Raffarin qui a été considéré
par de nombreux observateurs comme une
personne peut-être exagérément engagée
ou exagérément
j'ai envie de dire aligner avec le
narratif de Pékin
voilà quel genre d'attitude il faut
adopter vis-à-vis d'un État dont on
affirme qu'il a des menées ou des
velléités d'ingérence j'ajoute que
le Parlement français bien malgré nous
j'ai envie de dire puisque nous ne
voulions pas penser de la France
insoumise que un tel vote puisse naître
suivi d'aucun effet particulier le
Parlement français c'est prononcé pour
reconnaître une forme de génocide des
ouiours et je me demande ce que cela
peut bien faire pour Emmanuel Macron si
il est amené à rencontrer Monsieur
oxygène ping qu'est-ce que ça peut bien
lui faire de serrer la main d'un
génocidaire
parmi les autres exemples il y a
évidemment la question de la Turquie
madame la rapporteur a évoqué
l'assassinat que vraisemblablement la
Turquie à perpétré sur les assassinats
que la Turquie pourrait avoir perpétrée
sur le sol français la présomption est
très forte concernant ces militantes
Kurdes et ces militants kurdes quel
genre de relation du coup peut-on avoir
avec la Turquie selon vous et puis la
dernière question porte sur j'ai presque
envie de dire votre vie antérieure de
directrice de l'ENA quel genre de
précautions peuvent être être sont
prises ont été prises depuis au sein de
l'ENA par exemple mais aussi des des
grandes écoles françaises pour éviter
que
ces élites soient approchées de trop
près par par des États étrangers
je vais essayer de répondre à toutes vos
questions et si j'en ai oublié une
n'hésitez pas à me à me rappeler alors
si j'ose dire
sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon admettons qu'il
n'est pas besoin de conseiller c'est
rare pour avoir été moi-même ministre
j'étais heureuse d'avoir des conseillers
je trouve ça plutôt simple
à moins d'être un dieu vivant mais je ne
pense pas qu'il le revendique alors
mettons que ce soit ces positions
personnelles sans aucune influence qui
lui est fait dire que
Vladimir Poutine allait finir le travail
en Syrie qui lui fait parler à de
multiples reprises notamment dans des
explications de vote au Parlement
européen des nazis Ukrainiens
qui lui fait refuser en 2014 que enfin
votez contre la mise en place d'une
coopération scientifique
scientifique avec l'Ukraine ou d'une
aide financière à l'Ukraine en 2015 je
vous recommande aussi la lecture d'un
texte terrible qui est donc certainement
purement de sa plume et qui date de 2015
et qui s'appelle avant l'orage qui dit
ce qu'il pense de l'Ukraine et
permettez-moi de vous dire
que ça fait froid dans le dos
vous posez la question des entreprises
privées à quel moment peut-on dire
qu'elles sont manipulées par des états
et c'est une excellente question
difficile d'y répondre de manière
générale je dirais que il peut y avoir
parfois des législations
qui nous permettent d'avoir une idée
précise la loi sur la sûreté nationale
en Chine qui enjoint à des entreprises
comme Huawei ou comme Tik Tok enfin by
dance là la maison mère de Tik Tok
de communiquer
ce dont elles ont connaissance pour des
raisons de sécurité
et qui les enjoint c'est-à-dire qu'elles
ont l'obligation de le faire elles n'ont
pas le choix
nous permet de savoir que ces
entreprises
qu'elles ne veuille ou qu'elle ne le
veuille pas coopèrent avec le régime de
Pékin
cela justifie les précautions qui sont
de plus en plus prises et que de point
de vue je soutiens
vous aurez vu que le Parlement européen
a très rapidement demandé à
ceux qui travaillent de ne pas avoir
d'applications TikTok sur
leur outil de travail ce qui me paraît
frappé au coin du bon sens mais plus
largement la question des données des
entreprises de l'Internet est une
question suffisamment importante pour
que le l'Union européenne depuis
longtemps et de manière assez
prémonitoire ce soit penché dessus que
ce soit à travers le rgpd ou maintenant
à travers le DJ tout le service Act les
questions liées à Pegasus sont des
questions sur lesquelles une commission
d'enquête travail au Parlement européen
une commission spéciale pas une
commission d'enquête
et voilà exactement
combiner son son travail
il est là encore
important de pouvoir réglementer l'usage
de ce type de
logiciel de surveillance qui avait été
présenté comme de nature à permettre de
lutter contre les groupes terroristes et
qui ne le souhaiteraient pas et dont il
est forcé de constater que certains
états y compris dans l'Union européenne
leur réutilisé à l'encontre de certains
de leurs ressortissants alors dans ces
conditions faut-il voyager en Chine et
faut-il y emmener des hommes d'affaires
est-ce que la Chine va disparaître
demain de la carte non
est-ce que nous avons déclaré la guerre
à la Chine non
est-ce que on doit aller naïvement en
Chine sûrement pas et je me félicite que
Emmanuel Macron à la différence dans la
Scholtz ou à la différence de Pedro
Sanchez ne serait pas parti seul
en Chine mais avec
de la même manière que dans le monde a
précédent il avait accueilli c'était une
ping à Paris en compagnie à l'époque
d'angla Merkel et de Jean-Claude Juncker
le précédent président de la commission
je pense que
[Musique]
vis-à-vis de la Chine nous devons
essayer de convaincre ce pays de faire
des choix qui sont dans nos intérêts et
nous devons défendre nos intérêts
des choix par rapport à la guerre
d'invasion russe en Ukraine consistant
à ne pas être aussi complaisant que
Pékin l'est aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de
Moscou et à
résister à l'idée de lui livrer des
armes
des choix en matière de lutte contre le
changement climatique parce que tout ce
que nous tenterons de faire en Europe
trouvera ses limites si la Chine ne va
pas dans la même direction et beaucoup
plus vite qu'elle n'y va aujourd'hui
donc oui dialoguer mais avec les yeux
parfaitement ouvert sur ce que nous
avons pu constater
à la fois
en matière d'espionnage industrielle en
matière d'ingéron et en matière
d'agressivité diplomatique j'avais dit
rassumer puisque on a appelé ça la
diplomatie des loups guerriers un
certain nombre d'ambassadeurs chinois à
l'étranger et notamment en France non
pas manqué de discours que je
qualifierais de de provocateur
à destination des démocraties en général
et notamment de la France tout cela il
faut l'avoir en tête lorsque on parle à
des interlocuteurs je dirais d'une
manière générale de régime autoritaire
qui n'ont pas le même rapport ni autant
ni à la liberté d'expression
ni au droit de l'homme ni
forcément à la vérité dans le discours
public c'est plus compliqué de parler
avec eux qu'avec d'autres
mais ne se parlaient que dans
l'entre-soi des démocraties c'est aussi
en quelque sorte être dans sa bulle
informationnelle et ça permet pas de
faire évoluer les choses est-ce que ce
type de voyage est certain d'avoir des
une ici positive non
mais est-ce que c'est le rôle d'un chef
d'État de voir d'autres chefs d'État oui
ça j'en suis convaincu vous m'avez aussi
interrogé sur les grandes écoles puisque
j'ai eu l'honneur dans diriger une de le
faire de manière vigilante je ne cache
pas que c'est moi-même qui recrutait les
étudiants chinois qui venaient à l'École
nationale d'administration
et aucun de mes collaborateurs
j'y allais ayant une expérience
diplomatique puisque j'ai été diplomate
pendant 27 ans parlant moi-même chinois
et
cherchant à ne pas me faire imposer
des personnes qui n'auraient eu
de diplomates que le nom
et une fois que je les avais recrutés je
leur passais un message extrêmement
clair
sur leur comportement et à quel point ce
comportement se recruter de près pendant
leur scolarité
j'ai veillé à ne pas dépendre
financièrement de ce type de coopération
c'est là où un certain nombre de grandes
écoles
n'ont pas toujours la même prudence
c'est plus vrai à l'étranger qu'en
France puisqu'en France les universités
appliquent le même tarif quelle que soit
les étudiants qui qui étudie donc n'ont
pas un intérêt particulier à faire venir
des étudiants d'une nationalité
particulière mais si vous regardez les
écoles de commerce ça n'est pas le cas
si vous regardez Sciences Po ce n'est
pas le cas donc vous pouvez pour
arrondir les finances de votre école
être incité à avoir de plus en plus
d'étudiants d'une même nationalité et en
devenir de plus en plus dépendant ce qui
peut être en soi une véritable
difficulté ça peut être le cas donc pour
des coopérations scientifiques de la
même manière ça peut être le cas pour
des thincts de la même manière et
j'avais signé il y a quelques temps avec
une chercheuse française un appel à une
plus grande transparence sur le
financement des Simpson mais aussi un
meilleur financement public
parce que souvent si la recherche va
chercher de l'argent ailleurs c'est
qu'elle n'a pas assez d'argent public
français donc si on veut éravité éviter
les ingérences il faut aussi s'en donner
les moyens
mais le minimum serait la transparence
je n'ai aucun problème à assister à une
conférence qui va être financée par
l'ambassade de Chine si je sais qu'elle
est financée par l'ambassade de Chine
j'aurais beaucoup plus de problèmes si
je le découvrais par hasard et après
coup j'ai dit la Chine comme ça peut
être Taïwan comme ça peut être n'importe
quel autre pays je pense que cette
transparence manque et parmi les
recommandations que je fais au Parlement
européen après ce qu'on appelle le
catarget
et je ne sais pas si elles sont reprises
parce que ce n'est encore qu'un projet
de rapport qui n'est pas encore voté je
demande à la transparence sur le
financement des ONG avec lesquels nous
travaillons ou des experts auxquels nous
faisons appel je dirais là encore aucun
problème du moment que je sais d'où
vient l'argent qui finance l'expert qui
est devant moi
mais c'est la ministre la parole revient
après ce tour
je voudrais revenir sur ce que vous avez
dit sur l'influence chinoise
et une difficulté qui se pose une fois
plus ce n'est pas une question
rhétorique c'est une question qui se
pose à nos démocratie sur vous avez
évoqué l'origine de la pandémie et
comment effectivement nos démocraties en
pleine conscience
font la différence lorsque ce qui relève
du débat et de la question que on a le
droit de se poser étayer évidemment par
des faits et évidemment la tox et la
manipulation de la formation dans la
diffusion de la formation totalement
fausse vous l'avez dit le narratif
utilisé pour les messages honteux
ignoble sur l'invention du sida ont
effectivement été copié par le régime le
régime chinois sur mais l'origine du
covid il y a eu des questions qui
avaient été posées moi je n'ai aucun
avis sur le site le lien en étant donné
aucun avis sur l'origine du covid je
n'en sais rien question était posée
au consensus de l'OMS point final de ce
que dira mon état
ont été posé des questions sur
l'existence d'un laboratoire ensuite ça
a été estimé comme une fake news des
mesures ont été prises sans doute de
bonne foi d'ailleurs sur cette fake news
et finalement le débat était reposé je
ne sais pas où on en est ma question
d'ailleurs je cite cet exemple-là n'ont
pas pour savoir si oui ou non l'origine
de moi se nomme
de la défi voilà ce que je veux dire
voilà c'est intéressant comme du moment
où nos démocratie doivent lutter et
c'est pas facile je suis à te donner de
leçon de personne je le pose une
question pour qu'on avance pour qu'on
réussisse à construire quelque chose
ensemble enfin comme représentant de la
nation qui soit utile pour nos
compatriotes et pour nos partenaires
occidentaux d'autres démocraties dans le
monde de ce qui relève notamment quand
c'est d'ailleurs des des problèmes qui
viennent dans des régimes même
autoritaires ou évidemment tout en quête
internationale objectif tant qu'elle
scientifique et évidemment extrêmement
compliqué pour ne pas dire impossible
selon votre expérience comment on fait
aussi le ministre parce que vous avez
aussi connu des ressorts de l'État que
pour ma part j'ignore
comment on fait pour laisser
l'intelligence humaine prospérer
travailler enquêté avec le doute qui
quand même aussi une des bases de notre
civilisation doute constructive
d'outrationnelles un Palud délirant
évidemment et la lutte contre le fait
que voilà comment on fait pour
travailler sur ce ce genre de de sujets
qui sont délicats et qui inquiète aussi
et en plus qui font pas évidemment quand
on parle de maladie d'épidémie qui
évidemment en plus active des ressorts
sensibles c'est tout à chacun qui par
ailleurs vous l'avez dit prennent le
risque de l'hystérie
vous avez raison de relever que
s'agissant de la santé
c'est un thème idéal pour le
conspirationnisme
parce que
[Musique]
en particulier quand il s'agit de d'une
pandémie d'un virus inconnu
comme au départ on ne sait rien tout
devient petit possible tout devient
plausible
et quand des autorités d'État ont
l'honnêteté de dire comme l'ancien
Premier ministre avait fait plusieurs
reprises je ne sais pas c'est à la fois
très honnête mais certains on peut se
dire c'est pas possible après
c'est tout à fait possible quelque chose
est complètement nouveau c'est tout à
fait possible de ne pas savoir alors
comment on s'y retrouve pour éviter
d'être promené par les uns ou par les
autres
vous avez dit évidemment dans un régime
autoritaire il ne peut pas y avoir une
enquête indépendante
c'est ce qu'on a constant daté à
posteriori
c'est tout de même troublant que sur un
sujet de santé qui touchait la Chine
autant que le reste du monde il n'y ait
pas pu avoir
c'est à dire que l'autoritarisme a pris
quelque part le pas sur la recherche de
la vérité au bénéfice de l'intérêt
général
ce que l'on a constaté et qui
est un fait c'est la disparition
d'informations
sanitaire
disponible à
ce qu'on a constaté c'est la publication
de chiffres sur les morts du covid par
la Chine
qui d'abord cette interrompue assez vite
et quand elle avait lieu
était extrêmement peu plausible par
rapport à ce que l'on subissait ailleurs
à travers le monde
et des scientifiques ont fait des
hypothèses qui ne sont que des
hypothèses et ils le disent avec la
modestie des scientifique vous avez
raison de dire que le doute est
nécessaire en sciences mais ils ont fait
des hypothèses ces hypothèses montrent
toutes que les chiffres officiels
chinois ne sont pas crédibles
voilà ce que l'on peut dire ce que l'on
constate aussi c'est que l'OMS a eu
beaucoup de difficultés
à se rendre en Chine pour enquêter
se que l'on constate encore c'est la
présence extrêmement forte de la Chine
dans les organisations internationales
qui est due à une politique déterminée
depuis un certain nombre d'années mais
qui est dû aussi à une politique
américaine
erratique de retrait de ses
organisations internationales
qui ont laissé la place à d'autres
et un jour on se réveille en se disant
c'est tout de même curieux le nombre de
responsables chinois dans des
organisations de l'ONU à des postes
élevés
mais c'est vrai que quand les États-Unis
arrêtent de financer un certain nombre
d'organisations
la nature a horreur du vide
c'est cela que l'on peut constater
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en tirer comme
conclusion après ce ne sont plus que des
hypothèses mais on constate que la Chine
n'a pas aidé la communauté
internationale à faire la lumière sur la
manière dont le virus s'est propagé dans
son propre pays on constate aussi que
pour des raisons idéologiques la Chine
s'est opposée à ce que Taïwan soit
présent y compris en tant qu'observateur
dans à l'OMS pour faire état de sa
propre expérience de la pandémie et de
la manière dont Taïwan avait lutté
contre le covid ce qui était pourtant
important dans une pandémie de ce type
on a besoin des expériences de tous et
dans le passé Taïwan avait été
observateur à l'OMS
depuis le début du cogite Taïwan n'a pas
réussi à retrouver un statut
d'observateur par choix idéologique de
Pékin on est donc pas dans la recherche
de la vérité scientifique on est dans
une posture idéologique ce que
évidemment préoccupant
toujours on doit
s'interroger et jamais on ne doit
sombrer soi-même dans le
conspirationnisme Béa je suis pas de se
dire que
à quelque chose arrive c'est forcément
les Russes si j'ose dire
et vous l'avez vu lorsque vous avez
rencontré
l'ensis ou
le SGDSN là la frontière dans les
cyberattaques entre caractérisation et
attribution d'une concept frontière qui
n'est pas toujours facile à franchir qui
se franchit davantage parce que le
chemin faisant finit par accumuler de
l'expertise sur
d'où viennent les cyberatta comment
elles sont pratiquées etc
mais il faut toujours prendre le soin
avant d'avoir une idée très déterminée
d'essayer de de rassembler le plus
possible d'éléments si je reviens sur
les cyberattaques nous avons en commun
par le mot européen et Assemblée
nationale d'avoir voté une résolution
sur le lot de mort et d'avoir
immédiatement eu les honneurs d'une
cyberattaque
j'appelle ça si j'ose dire une
cyberattaque publicitaire
ça n'est pas la plus grave en termes de
conséquences c'est une manière de dire
à chaque fois que vous toucherez à un
sujet lié à la Russie
nous pouvons nous en prendre à vous soit
je dirais si ça n'est que ça
c'est presque pathétique on se demande
s'il n'y a pas quelque part quelqu'un
dans un bureau
a donné une instruction
presque bureaucratique russe de dire
résolution désagréable cyberattaque
si ce n'est que ça c'est des agréable
pendant quelques heures et puis on s'en
sort attention à ce que ce ne soit pas
la couverture
d'attaque qui elle pourrait être plus
profonde c'est par exemple ce que le
Parlement européen est aujourd'hui
appelé à vérifier à chaque fois et il a
développé ses compétences en
cybersécurité parce qu'on peut avoir le
nez braqué sur le fait que l'écran de
l'Assemblée ou les l'écran du Parlement
n'affiche rien et puis il peut se passer
d'autres choses pendant ce temps-là il
faut à chaque fois prendre le temps
travailler avec les experts
les experts les plus larges possible si
je tire ce qui nous aide aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on appelle le renseignement
en source ouverte
qui s'est beaucoup
développé qui permet
de documenter l'origine d'une image où
elle a été prise à quel moment elle a
été prise vous souvenez peut-être que
ce renseignement source ouverte qui ne
vient pas de service de renseignement
qui vient de
d'internautes un peu doué qui se sont
spécialisés et j'en ai rencontré un
certain nombre pour essayer de
comprendre ça n'est pas mon cas je vous
le dis tout de suite mais pour essayer
de comprendre comment ils pratiquait ça
a permis de savoir que un certain nombre
de déclarations devraient Dimir Poutine
pendant la guerre du crâne avait été
enregistré bien avant un événement
auquel ils étaient censés répondre
ce qui en soi est une information
ce qui permet de savoir qu'il y avait
une volonté et que à un moment où le
monde extérieur n'avait pas conscience
de cette volonté la déclaration était
elle-même déjà enregistrée cela est
clair beaucoup notre capacité à
comprendre des régimes aussi fermés qui
par ailleurs font évidemment tout pour
qu'on ne sache pas quelle est leur
processus de décision
merci madame la ministre
précise ok désolé beaucoup de questions
se posent beaucoup de choses en polymère
donc si
le faire un tunnel n'hésitez pas si vous
avez une question à poser à me dire que
je m'interromps pour que la poser une
question
très bien voilà mais c'est pour la
méthode fixant j'aime bien fixer le
méthode de travail pour que tout se
passe bien vous avez mentionné ça m'a
interpellé le cas du caviargate donc
mettant en cause l'Azerbaïdjan et vous
avez pensé là pour le couple les
bienfaits attention à noter les mots
parce que c'est ils étaient forts qui a
eu des tentatives d'assassinat sur notre
sol est-ce que vous parlez est-ce que
c'est bien la bonne phrase évidemment
que j'ai bien noté est-ce que notre sol
c'est le sol français ou est-ce que
c'est le seul européen c'est pas une
attaque c'est on peut considérer que
notre sol pour certaines personnes ce
qui n'est pas bien frustré et l'ensemble
du de partenaires européens voire le
continent européen lui-même à la je n'ai
pas moi connaissance de ces tentatives
d'assassinat je pense que ceux qui nous
écoutent on peut être interpellé donc si
vous pouvez développer des faits qui
sont évidemment d'une extrême gravité
alors il s'agit d'un jeune blogueur
raseri qui s'appelle Mohamed miosali qui
a trouvé refuge en France son crime
c'est de dénoncer ce que lui considère
comme étant la corruption du régime de
l'âme alief
il a trouvé refuge en France il a le
statut de réfugiés politiques
et il a fait l'objet de trois tentatives
d'assassinat sur notre sol et quand je
dis notre sol c'est le sol français
à son domicile à l'extérieur de son
domicile
sans compter les innombrables menaces de
mort qu'il continue à recevoir il fait
l'objet aujourd'hui d'une protection
policière
et je considère que
[Musique]
à partir du moment où nous accordons
l'asile politique
à quelqu'un
si les menacé sur notre sol c'est un
déni de souveraineté à notre endroit
pour moi c'est quelque chose de très de
très grave c'est un peu comparable
avec les actions que l'on a attribué à
l'époque au Loup-gris turc
qui sont pris à des
français d'origine arménienne vivant en
France ou à des Kurdes réfugiés en
France et ce qui a conduit à la
dissolution par le ministre de
l'intérieur de cette association des
loups-gris une association
ultra violente proche du pouvoir turc à
chaque fois que des pays étrangers
croient pouvoir
se servir de notre territoire pour
régler leur compte avec leur dissident
je considère que c'est à la fois une
ingérence et un déni de notre
souveraineté de la même manière lorsque
Monsieur scripal et sa fille font
l'objet d'un empoisonnement sur le
territoire britannique c'est la même
chose c'est d'ailleurs cela avait
déclenché des sanctions prises de
manière coordonnée par un certain nombre
de pays européens pas tout à fait tous
mais quand même un certain nombre
je vous remercie madame Loiseau
vous avez mentionné et
ça m'intéresse parce que j'ai moi-même
posé cette question lors de plusieurs
auditions on y reviendra sur les
ingérences de pays finançant les fermes
musulmans et l'islamisme en général
mais aussi ce qui est un problème je
trouve largement ignoré en France alors
qu'il commence à être ancien puisque je
me souviens je m'en souviens inquiété
moi quand j'étais étudiant à l'ESSEC à
Cergy ayant constaté physiquement la
présence de ces nouveaux groupes
religieux
avant groupe chrétien que vous avez donc
d'aspiration à l'époque en tout cas pour
ce cas d'espèces évangélique et donc
malheureusement ça fait maintenant
18 ans
18 ans et je constate que ce mouvement
prospère alors la plupart évidemment le
fond dans le respect de de nos lois à
nos valeurs parce que certains ont réagi
en disant que le mettait en cause c'est
les pâtes ça mais faut-il encore le
préciser mais vous l'avez mentionné
certains de ces mouvements que ce soit
en Europe alors il y a en plus on a
quand même le précédent notamment en
Amérique du Sud enfin déjà le précédent
Amérique du Nord mais on a aussi le le
précédent en Amérique du Sud donc on a
on ne s'est renseigné cette étudié
d'ailleurs par beaucoup d'experts de de
ces pays qui ont étudié ces cas et donc
on sait très bien comment il procède
d'ailleurs
et en France effectivement c'est très
peu c'est très peu débattu
et donc je voulais savoir si vous pouvez
revenir justement sur ces moments quel
est votre regard parce que effectivement
ce sont des mouvements qui prospects qui
font passer des idéologies d'une manière
très différente en plus
peut-être aussi avoir votre garde
là-dessus des traditions religieuses
françaises chrétiennes voilà donc on
n'est pas spécialement habitué aussi à
l'étage il y a une tradition d'État
gérés de religion c'est des pratiques
une expérience des habitudes des
contacts une hiérarchique qui n'existe
pas forcément ailleurs voilà et donc
est-ce que vous pouvez revenir sur ce
sur ce cadre d'espèces que vous avez
mentionné parce que j'imagine que si
vous l'avez souhaité dans votre propos
liminaire c'est qu'il vous inquiète
autant qu'il m'inquiète moi
je vous avoue qu'effectivement
lorsqu'on voit mis en cause des droits
et j'allais dire un modèle de société
qui que nous avons choisi celui où les
femmes et les hommes sont à égalité
celui où les minorités sont protégées
et que ces mises en cause viennent de
l'extérieur on tique forcément
je vous avoue que la première fois que
j'ai été appelée à
que j'étais interpellé c'est lorsque
j'étais au gouvernement et que je voyais
j'ai beaucoup notamment en Europe
centrale et orientale et que c'était le
moment où la convention d'Istanbul
pension qui consacrait à la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes un sujet
a priori sur lequel on devrait être à
peu près d'accord ou alors il y a un
très gros sujet
cette ratification de la Convention
d'Istanbul
sûreté a des difficultés dans plusieurs
pays de l'Est
et pour avoir vécu aux États-Unis je
j'allais dans des universités je
rencontrais des étudiants je veux bien
de l'eau je vous remercie monsieur le
Président
je découvrais
des termes
qui me paraissait moins spontanément
croate ou bulgare et est très copier
coller de ce que j'avais entendu moi aux
Etats-Unis
et j'étais un peu prise de cours
à me demander pourquoi d'abord je
retrouvais les mêmes termes partout et
pourquoi ces termes me rappelait les 5
ans que j'ai passé à Washington
on s'est aperçu petit à petit j'ai
interrogé là encore des experts que en
effet il y avait des organisations
transnationales notamment ce qu'on
appelle
qui promouvait ce que eux appellent des
valeurs familiales traditionnelles
nous sommes en train de parler de choses
légales mais ça n'est pas parce que une
activité légale qu'elle n'est pas
préoccupante quand il s'agit de
d'ingérence étrangère
et c'est toute la difficulté de votre
travail comme de celui de la Commission
dans laquelle je siège c'est qu'on parle
souvent d'activité légale mais sur
lequel on a au moins mettre le
projecteur pour savoir quand quelque
chose est importé de l'extérieur sans
avoir été sollicitée et vous avez une
partie des évangiles américains et je me
garderai de généraliser pour qui ce
combat est un combat mondial
qu'il convient de mener en aidant tous
ceux qui ici ou la porte la même vision
à la diffuser et vous retrouvez en
famille ce que je disais rapidement dans
mon introduction des gens qui
normalement ne devraient pas s'asseoir
les uns à côté des autres des
évangéliques américains des
représentants russes qui sont proches de
la mouvance de Constantin maloffer dont
on sait le choix qu'il a fait d'aller
vers la promotion de ce que lui aussi
appelle la famille traditionnelle et des
Polonais proches par exemple Bordeaux
youris qui est aujourd'hui une NG
polonaise très puissante très active à
Bruxelles qui dicte un certain nombre de
députés européens ce qui peut vous qui
ne peuvent pas accepter dans des textes
européens et qui a son origine au Brésil
chez les évangéliques
ça fait une espèce de
ratatouille
ce sont des gens qui sont d'accord sur
ces principes là et qui surtout se
mobilisent et dépenses de l'argent pour
que ces principes arrivent dans nos pays
alors vous parlez de valeur
de pratique traditionnelles chrétiennes
en France
disons-le la France est un pays où on
pratique moins qu'on a pratiqué
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il y a moins
besoin de spiritualité je n'en sais rien
je n'en suis pas sûr
je vois que des rassemblements
évangéliques ont du succès
parfois là où des églises plus
traditionnelles sont un peu vides
je vois que des communautés
y trouvent un accueil qu'elle considère
comme bienveillant je vois la puissance
de certaines églises évangéliques aux
Antilles je la vois dans des communautés
d'origine africaine
qui sont profondément chrétiennes mais
qui ont trouvé une forme de pratique une
forme d'accueil
qui les a séduit et tant mieux si mais
quand il y a par ailleurs et ça n'est
pas le cas je ne veux pas généraliser
quand il y a par ailleurs chez certains
un agenda que je qualifierai de purement
politique là j'en viens à m'inquiéter et
je rappelle que le premier rassemblement
qui est en France est à l'origine de la
diffusion du covid était malheureusement
et bien sûr qu'ils n'en sont pas
responsables mais un rapport
rassemblement évangélique et que la plus
grande difficulté a été que ce
rassemblement n'avait pris les identités
de personnes et que ceux qui sont
repartis ont répondu le virus à travers
notre pays
merci Madame Lamy c'est écoutez
j'enchaîne sur évidemment qui est le
lien entre ces deux familles avec
l'influence que vous avez souligné des
Frères musulmans vous avez notamment et
l'estime avec un certain courage madame
nommer le problème du féminismeau et
vous avez dit qu'il avait des
financements de la Commission européenne
comment
très peu ton justement
avancer sur ce sujet là comment vous
pensez la représentation nationale
s'interroge en tout cas en France
puisque nous avons un modèle de laïcité
qui est original
certains consensus pour dire qu'on s'en
somme fiers et que peu de force
politique représentées au parlement
souhaite à le remettre le remettre en
cause
ce n'est pas forcément la même tradition
que nos partenaires européens évidemment
qu'il en plus pas non plus même
tradition non seulement avec la religion
générale mais avec ceux qui défendent
des opinions religieuses ou des
convictions religieuses ou des
convictions spirituelles puisque on va
dire que la France conception large de
l'application de la laïcité mon avis a
juste titre
donc voilà comment vous avez fait un
état des lieux donc comment vous c'est
une fois plus ça le but de cette
commission c'est l'information mais oui
c'est pas facile pour vous vous demande
beaucoup de choses et conscience
une fois qu'on a fait le diagnostic
voilà comment est-ce qu'on peut avancer
sur ce sujet là
pour éviter toute forme nous de
financement d'organisation visiblement
islamiste et aussi
comment dire limiter ou éradiquer les
formes de financement étrangers qui
viennent se mêler d'organisation de
l'affaire religieuse de nos compatriotes
ou d'étrangers en situation régulière
alors vaste question je vais essayer d'y
répondre de manière très très modeste
parce que
ma première maintenant je suis sur le
sujet et si c'était si simple ce serait
probablement déjà fait au niveau
européen vous l'avez très bien dit la
conception française de la laïcité n'est
pas nécessairement partagée partout et
partout mais la préoccupation vis-à-vis
des ingérences oui
et je dirais la question de
pourquoi la Commission Amanda ou n'a pas
mandat
et pour moi
[Musique]
il faut rendre assez Rasses qui est à
César Dieu ce qui est à Dieu chacun
chacun fait ce qu'il a à faire et je ne
suis pas sûr que la Commission est à
financer des associations religieuses
quelle qu'elle soit
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait au niveau
européen puis après j'essaierai très
très prudemment et très modestement
d'aborder le sujet français au niveau
européen j'ai fait voter à deux reprises
dans une résolution de plénière du
Parlement européen des amendements qui
demandaient que
l'institutions européennes
fasse preuve de prudence et de
responsabilité vis-à-vis d'association
qui font la promotion du port du voile
islamique
et bien ces deux ces deux fois ces
amendements ont été votés
ce qui prouve qu'il y avait une majorité
très au-delà de mon groupe politique
pour les voter
c'est donc plutôt une bonne nouvelle
ensuite
essayez de démêler de démêler les
chevaux de quelles associations
portant quel nom travaille sur quel
agenda n'est pas toujours facile pour la
commission quand il s'agit de promouvoir
la Genèse l'inclusivité la diversité
tout ça sont des causes extrêmement
sympathiques
la question est de savoir si derrière il
y a un financement étranger pour nous
faire changer notre mode de vie et là ça
s'appelle une ingérence
je dois dire que pour avoir commencé à
en parler depuis que je suis corps
rapporteur d'un g donc depuis quelques
semaines en réalité avec des membres
éminents de la commission je suis plutôt
heureusement surprise de leur prise de
conscience peut-être tardive sûrement
tardive
mais je n'ai pas d'interlocuteur qui me
disent circuler il y a rien à voir
j'ai des interlocuteurs qui me disent on
ne peut pas travailler avec des
associations qui sont des chevaux de 3
de puissance étrangères
et là dessus
ça me met assez à l'aise je vais
continuer le travail avec elle pour voir
dans quelle direction ça va parce que
c'est très facile de se lever dans
l'admissible et de dénoncer on sait tous
faire ça
mais derrière trouver une solution et
faire quelle marche ça me paraît plus
important et c'est ce que dans mon
groupe politique on s'efforce de faire
je dis tout ça avec beaucoup de modestie
parce que nous sommes au début d'un
chemin qui
il a d'abord fallu convaincre et
convaincre une majorité la posture
isolée n'est pas pour moi autre chose
que de la posture et puis après il faut
trouver des pare-feux en France je pense
que beaucoup de choses ont été faites
après des décennies d'une culture ou en
quelque sorte
s'agissant d'une religion en particulier
la religion musulmane on avait considéré
comme naturel que
il y a par exemple ce qu'on appelle un
islam consulaire
c'est à dire que des imams et les
mosquées soient sous la responsabilité
de pays étrangers
au bout de plusieurs générations de
musulmans nés en France et de
nationalité française on peut se poser
la question de savoir
si on a vraiment besoin de faire appel à
l'étranger
d'une manière régulière ou pendant le
mois de Ramadan pour avoir
des
des prêcheurs musulmans
on peut espérer que ce soit de moins en
moins le cas
et on doit s'assurer que
lorsqu'un financement est étranger ou
lorsque après cher est étranger il n'est
pas antipathique au motif qu'il était
étranger comprenons-nous bien mais
l'idée d'une charte qui a été mise en
place sur les valeurs partagées est
évidemment une idée qui a permis de voir
que certains ne voulaient pas signer la
charte et c'est en soi extrêmement
éclairant
ça permet
d'objectiver le débat de pas se mettre à
dire attention il peut partout parce que
ça n'est pas vrai
mais de permettre de se dire tiens là
c'est un peu curieux quand même puis une
fois qu'on a signé une charte soit on
l'applique soit on applique pas
il y a deux ce point de vue semble-t-il
beaucoup d'avancer qui sont faites avec
beaucoup de gens de bonne foi
ensuite
est-ce que la pratique je dirais qui
consiste à se rendre à la mosquée et la
pratique la plus répandue parmi les
musulmans en France et donc celles qui
permet le plus d'ingérence étrangère je
suis pas sûr
c'est un élément mais ce n'est pas
nécessairement le seul les réseaux
sociaux sont là aussi où les chaînes de
télévision étrangères sont là aussi
quelque chose qui mérite
au moins de la transparence de la mise
en lumière du débat et de l'exercice de
l'esprit critique nous ne voulons pas
devenir
ce que sont les pays que nous critiquons
les pays autoritaires se mettent à
fermer ici et là des traits des
télévisions dans tous les sens en disant
mais
mettre en lumière
expliquer exposer
ce que fait par exemple une chercheuse
du CNRS qui en ce moment se heurte
à beaucoup de critiques
parce que son livret est courageuse je
parle je parle de Florence berger
blacker que vous avez peut-être
auditionné qui a écrit un livre sur le
frérisme et ses réseaux
faire que l'on sache
me paraît
déjà une bonne approche et j'ai essayé
très rapidement dans mon livre parce que
je ne suis pas aussi experte
de voir ce qu'il en était
je salue le travail aussi de gens comme
Christian chez nous et Georges malbruno
qui ont parlé
des pays du Golfe
de ce qui a été leur attitude qui n'est
pas nécessairement celle d'aujourd'hui
il y a une prise de conscience
internationale sur les financements de
l'islam radical qui a parfois porté
atteinte à la réputation de certains
pays qui se qui en ont conclu que
fallait être plus attentif donc là non
plus je ne veux pas généraliser ni dans
l'espace ni dans le temps mais c'est
parce qu'il y a assez mis en lumière qui
peut y avoir une évolution positive
merci
merci monsieur le Président alors le
sujet que je voulais aborder mais j'ai
une deuxième question bien sûr
a été évoqué à l'instant c'était celui
effectivement la somme de réseau et
notamment est-ce que votre livre en fait
état également de l'utilisation
extrêmement
perfectionné que font un centre de
réseau islamiste et a commencé par des
organisations théoriques comme ça de
daesh des nouvelles technologies et là
aussi il y a des mécanismes à l'oeuvre
qui sont extrêmement dangereux pour nos
pour nos démocraties et qu'on ne doit
certainement pas oublier même s'il peut
y avoir des actualités y compris en
termes de géopolitique des
géostratégiques qui gardent nos
inquiétudes et nos efforts et notre
solidarité plus plus vers l'Est mais
nous avons des défis et notamment celui
du djihadisme islamiste toujours très
à ardemment posé à notre démocratie
ma question en fait n'est pas une
question qui qui vient conclure cette
audition mais en fait je mettais quand
même intéressé à ce que vous disiez en
conclusion de votre de votre ouvrage
parce que vous écrivez que vous estimez
que nos alors je vais essayer de vous
citer nos j'ouvre les guillemets aussi
système politique économique
l'organisation de notre société
elle-même ne sont pas suffisamment
adaptées aux grands bouleversements de
notre temps technologique bien
évidemment démographique
environnementaux
identitaire et culturel donc nous avons
encore des marges de progrès accomplir
pour remédier à cette inadaptation et
cette voilà nous on appréhension
suffisamment efficace des phénomènes qui
nous menacent d'ingérence d'influence
d'interférences etc etc quels sont alors
vous en avez esquissez quelques-unes par
transparence sur le financement étranger
de certains thinkings etc mais quels
seront quelles seraient les grandes
directions les grandes préconisations
que forcément dé voiler tous les travaux
que vous menez au titre de un G2 vous
auriez envie de nous partager
alors nous sommes intéressés au pays qui
avait vécu
j'allais dire la guerre hybride de la
manière la plus violente et qui quand il
s'agit de l'Ukraine sont passés
directement la galerie de la guerre tout
court
parce que c'est parfois un substitut
mais parfois une préparation à quelque
chose de plus professionnel comme comme
conflit et c'est intéressant de voir
quand une société devient résiliente à
la désinformation
la corruption d'élite comme les devenus
la société ukrainienne de manière
probablement imprévisible pour Vladimir
Poutine c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un peu c'est un peu plan d'armes
c'est au-delà d'une armée plus vaillante
contre le français etc etc au-delà de
l'aide occidentale si vous avez pas une
société qui tient le coup
une espèce de force morale de la société
ça ne marcherait pas
Taïwan c'est
un peu comparable dieu merci Taïwan a
pas fait l'objet de la version militaire
mais la guerre hybride qui les menée par
par Pékin et constante et on voit cette
idée que c'est toute la société qui qui
doit se sentir concerné alors c'est
difficile de dire ça en France parce que
on a une exception française qui moi m'a
frappé pour avoir été diplomate et avoir
vécu un peu partout c'est qu'ici dès
qu'il se passe quelque chose que fait
l'état
c'est quand même le réflexe français par
excellence et puis dès que l'état fait
quelque chose on critique comme ça on
est parfaitement français parfaitement à
l'aise
je dirais que pour le coup les
ingérences c'est l'affaire de chacun
c'est l'affaire d'une culture
non pas du soupçon et de la méfiance
parce que ce serait détestable et on
tomberait dans l'espèce de complotisme
facile
mais de la conscience
que
au fond
nous sommes
c'est difficile à dire dans un pays qui
se croit fatigué en déclin etc notre
sort est en viable et qu'il est la cible
d'un certain nombre de
régime autoritaire qui aimerait bien que
nous soyons différents et sans doute
moins attractif
si on a conscience de ça
on voit mieux
quand certains nombre de choses se
passent
et on y réfléchit avant de plonger dans
la naïveté j'aimerais que les
universités les grandes écoles
s'interrogent avant de signer à tour de
bras des partenariats avec
des instituts chinois spécialisés dans
des activités duales alors maintenant il
y a un travail qui est fait mais je sais
qu'au début quand j'en parlais avec des
présidents d'université ou grandes
écoles
eux me trouver très très complotiste
c'est formidable
c'est formidable sauf quand ça les moins
j'ai le souvenir d'un
thuriféraire du régime de Pékin invité à
une conférence
co-organisée par l'Université de Brest
et l'École navale et qui est passé son
temps à expliquer aux étudiants que le
modèle politique chez nous était bien
supérieur à nos démocraties étaient
indispensable je suis pas sûr alors oui
liberté d'expression liberté d'opinion
capacité de roter son esprit critique à
des opinions très différentes
très bien mais à condition que ce soit
vraiment présenté comme ça et ça ne
l'est pas toujours donc cette espèce de
naïveté
je la trouve confondante quand je vois
le porte-parole le l'ambassade russe sur
les médias français souvent et pas
toujours contredit parce que pourquoi
pas si vous avez en face quelqu'un qui
tient la route et qui sait lui dire non
mais là écoutez
ces flagrant que c'est inexact c'est
arrivé une fois
le reste du temps il a la part belle je
me demande toujours si le porte-parole
de l'ambassade de France à Moscou fait
l'objet du même traitement la réponse
est facile évidemment non
pourquoi ça faiblir face
à un régime dont il faut lire les
dernières déclarations qui sont tout de
même peu à même vis-à-vis de nous
pourquoi alors bien sûr les médias ont
toute latitude de faire ce qu'ils
veulent mais il est aussi une
responsabilité et je pense que quand je
vois répertoire sans frontières mettent
en avant une espèce d'autorégulation des
médias
je serai la dernière à leur dire quoi
faire parce que je pense qu'un politique
qui dit au média quoi faire c'est
détestable mais je trouve ça intéressant
que ce début de réflexion existe moi
j'aimerais beaucoup que quand on a des
invités dans les médias quel qu'il soit
on les présente moins pour ce qu'ils ont
été que pour ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
quand je vois d'anciens généraux
d'anciens ministres
d'anciens ambassadeurs ça ne me dit rien
sur la raison qui font qui fait qu'ils
acceptent une interview aujourd'hui
alors ça peut être l'ego le narcissisme
personne n'est à l'abri mais ça peut
être aussi qu'ils sont à la tête d'un
cabinet de relation publique pourquoi
pas c'est légal mais je pense que de la
même manière que vous et moi aimer en
savoir ce que nous mangeons et quels
sont les ingrédients les ingrédients de
l'information sont pas moins importants
et savoir très simplement que les médias
décident très simplement de présenter
tel ou tel non pas pour ce qu'il a été
mais pour son activité professionnelle
d'aujourd'hui
me paraîtrait de nature à faire en sorte
que l'on sache d'où il ou elle parle
j'ai entendu des des gens parler de
l'urgence de diversifier notre
approvisionnement en gaz à cause de la
Russie là il se trouve que je partageais
leur point de vue
mais quand je savais par ailleurs qu'il
travaillait pour des entreprises
cathariennes
bon
c'est aussi bien de savoir
ça fait partie des alors après sur des
choses plus clairement politique je suis
quand même très frappé
de la concomitance en tout cas de la
similitude entre les stands dehors et
d'une certaine manière celui de François
Fillon même si François Fillon a quitté
ses activités en Russie ce qui n'est pas
le cas de guerre entre
j'ai tendance à penser que personne
n'est obligé de devenir Premier ministre
que là encore c'est un choix c'est un
choix qui engage parce qu'à partir du
moment où vous êtes chef de gouvernement
où vous avez accès à des secrets d'État
et que il me semblerait pas choquant
que on oblige quelqu'un à prendre
l'engagement de ne pas travailler par la
suite pour un pays étranger qui ne fasse
pas partie d'une alliance à laquelle
nous appartenons au minimum au minimum
on peut dire pour n'importe quel pays
étranger mais alors après vous allez
dire ah oui mais un pays qui s'est
effondré je voudrais l'aider à se à se
reconstruire j'arrive de Somalie donc
pour ce qui était payé fondé j'en ai un
bien en tête et si quelqu'un veut demain
aider la Somalie se reconstruire
pourquoi pas mais au moins un pays qui
nous est pas hostile alors c'est
compliqué à définir mais je trouve une
ressembler
qu'on se pose ce type de questions avant
de prendre ce type de responsabilité qui
fait que on a accès à des secrets d'État
tout simplement je pense que ça
accroîtrait aussi la confiance que nous
concitoyens accorde aux politiques je
pense que nous en avons bien besoin
merci monsieur le Président alors je
vais juste continuer par rapport à notre
échange précédent pour vous attester
donc pour vous prouver que c'était pas
une volonté de déformer vos propos mais
le compte rendu le replay vous vous
disiez bien ce sont des voyages on est
payé par des interlocuteurs du pays donc
vous voyez d'avoir interrogé d'avoir
voulu réinformer vous vous posez la
question permet indirectement de
préciser vos propos et donc je suis très
heureux parce que j'étais très inquiet
face à telle révélation vous avez évoqué
à nouveau le choix de contracter pour un
parti politique pour un candidat avec
une banque non française ça pose la
question de la banque de la démocratie
qui était une promesse du président de
la République promet soutenu par un
certain nombre de dirigeants politiques
notamment Monsieur Bayrou est-ce que
vous considérez que c'est quelque chose
qui pourrait permettre d'éviter
d'éventuelles ingérences de donner cette
liberté cette capacité si je considère
que c'est pas un choix mais souvent une
nécessité une obligation du fait de
refus des banques françaises est-ce que
cette banque de la démocratie pour vous
est une bonne chose et que la promesse
non tenue pour le moment du président de
la République devrait donner lieu à une
évolution avant la fin de son mandat ça
c'était le premier première question la
deuxième vous l'avez évoqué rapidement
c'est le catargate
et quelles sont vos tirez cet épisode
qui a frappé le Parlement européen
et qui a touché le Parti socialiste les
parties socialistes européens vous avez
vos ketchup 4 Gérard chaudeur on en
parle rarement on en parle très peu
notamment en France je voulais savoir
quel était votre position et quelles
leçons vous tiriez de cet épisode et
enfin vous avez évoqué le cas du de
François Fillon moi j'ai le cas c'est
peut-être en tant que régional parce que
je suis une région centrale de Loire et
qu'il y en ait originaire je pense à
Maurice Leroy ancien ministre qui est
actuellement payé par l’argent russe
puisque employer par une entreprise
publique russe pour le grand Moscou
Maurice thorac avait soutenu Emmanuel
Macron dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 est-ce que vous
considérez comme vous l'avez dit que ça
vous pose question et que ça devrait
donner lieu à des interdictions à des
inter dictions
d'emplois de rejoindre des conseils
d'administration soit d'entreprises
privées ou là dans le cas d'espèces
d'entreprises publiques dès lors qu'on
est occupé un certain nombre de postes à
responsabilité qu'on est détenteur d'un
certain nombre de
d'informations de secret voir des de
secrets d'État et d'informations qui et
de lien avec un certain nombre de
personnalités qui sont aujourd'hui
encore en poste est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui est dans la continuité ce que
vous avez dit pour Monsieur Fillon peut
se prêter pour pour Monsieur le roi
alors j'ai commencé par la dernière
question d'abord j'ai une question de
conscience quand on se retrouve dans un
pays qui commet l'agression comme elle a
réussi vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine je serai
toujours surprise et je serai toujours
en désaccord avec le fait qu'on est à
soi-même tout simplement un cas de
conscience ensuite ce que Monsieur le
roi était tenteur de secret d'état je
n'en suis pas convaincu contenu des
postes qu'il a pu occuper dans le passé
et je l'ai dit dans les recommandations
que je préconise y compris pour les
parlementaires européens c'est la
question de ce qu'on appelle Revol
indoor en très bon français de pas se
mettre à travailler comme le vieilliste
pour un pays étranger au moment où on
quitte son ses fonctions ça me paraît
tout simplement
ça voilà
je dis j'allais dire quel que soit le
pays c'est peut-être mon caractère
d'ancien fonctionnaires diplomate de mon
pays qui me fait dire ça mais quel que
soit le pays étranger il y a un mélange
des genres que que moi j'ai du mal à
que j'ai du mal à accepter redites moi
vos autres questions parce que j'ai fait
la bêtise de ne pas prendre de papier et
donc
les leçons vous tiriez de l'épisode du
Qatar game notamment pour le Parti
socialiste européen qui avait déjà en
fait indirectement été touché par le
cage Gérard Schröder dans d'autres dans
d'autres conditions bien entendu et puis
après c'était la question sur la bande
de démocratie votre position sur la
banque de la démocratie qui permettrait
peut-être développer un certain nombre
de problématiques il y a des prêts à
étrangers
alors le catarget comme je le dis j'y
vais avec précaution dans la mesure où
quand une enquête
une procédure judiciaire est en cours
présente son innocence on ne sait pas
absolument tout la presse notamment la
presse belge et manifestement nourrie de
l'intérieur par beaucoup d'éléments
parce que tout est vrai ce que tout
n'est pas vrai je n'en sais rien
est-ce qu'on aurait pu le prévenir ça
s'est évidemment la question qui se pose
à la rapporteur que je suis
ce qu'on peut empêcher des gens d'être
malhonnête
c'est presque une épreuve de philosophie
au bac est-ce que on peut est-ce qu'on
doit surtout
mettre dans notre Parlement plus de
transparence là où il y avait de
l'opacité et plus de protection là où il
y avait trop d'ouvertures c'est ma
conviction il y a pas de culture de
sécurité dans le Parlement européen
vraiment aucune et moi compte tenu de
mon parcours professionnel j'ai plaidé
pour cette culture de sécurité dès que
je suis arrivé au Parlement européen
enfin n'importe qui peut pas avoir un
accès à n'importe quoi tout le temps
peut pas se retrouver avec des
représentants de pays étrangers qui se
promènent sans être accompagné dans les
couloirs de ce Parlement ce qu'on a
constaté à maintes reprises
je pense en ce moment par exemple
représentant des mujahidines du peuple
qui passent leur vie dans les couloirs
de Strasbourg ça ne me paraît pas
indispensable et je vois aux sourcils du
président Tanguy peut-être à lui non
plus
oui
parce qu'ils sont enregistrés bon certes
mais moi je demande maintenant tout
simplement qu'il soit accompagné et qui
n'aille pas partout comme il le souhaite
ça paraît assez basique comme demande
donc il y avait cette extrême ouverture
là où on aurait dû se protéger et à
l'inverse ce manque de transparence
sur qui on rencontre moi c'est assez
simple à chaque fin de semaine je publie
mon agenda sur les réseaux sociaux
pourquoi à la fin de la semaine parce
qu'il change pendant la semaine si je le
mets au début et que c'est pas
exactement ce que j'ai fait ça n'est pas
transparent il y a tout le monde sauf
des personnes qui se font l'objet de
persécution et que je mettrai en danger
mais en revanche pour le blogueur azzeri
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure ça le
protège que je montre que nous nous
voyons c'est lui qui me l'a dit donc à
chaque fois nous nous prenons en photo
et j'indique que nous nous sommes vus
pas nécessairement où et je ne publie
pas tout de suite au moment où nous nous
sommes vus pour le protéger
transparence sur qui on voit
transparence sur qui on rencontre pour
rédiger un rapport
très simplement faire la liste des
personnes qu'on a rencontré pour rédiger
un rapport me paraît je dirais simple et
sain j'ai été co-auteur du rapport sur
l'Arménie je suis prête très simplement
à dire qui j'ai rencontré
j'aimerais que ceux qui ont rédigé le
rapport sur laserbaïdjan face la même
chose
et comme ça tout le monde sait
après c'est pas le soupçon au contraire
je pense que ça clarifier des choses
et quand on voyage on dit qu'on voyage
très simplement y compris quand c'est
pas le Parlement européen ce genre de
choses me paraît indispensable
je voudrais pas que le catarget cache la
forêt des autres ingérences
ça c'est une préoccupation ça n'est pas
parce que ce serait le Qatar et ce
serait les sociaux-démocrates qui a pas
d'autres ingérences d'autres pays à
destination d'autres députés d'autres
groupes ça vous connaissez la formule
quand le sage montre la lune imbécile
regarde le doigt je veux pas être l'un
des cils dans l'histoire j'ai vu deux
groupes politiques en pressés de dire il
faut fermer la commission un G2 et faire
une commission spéciale cathare
ça c'est le contraire de ce qu'il faut
faire là c'est l'imbécile qui regarde le
doigt qui dit il y a un problème avec
les socialistes et le Qatar
non il y a un problème avec les
ingérences et tout le monde moi je suis
incapable de vous dire si demain
quelqu'un montre politique j'espère que
non mais je suis pas capable de vous
dire ça m'est arrivé à personne jamais
et je préfère prendre des précautions
pour que ça n'arrive pas plutôt que de
me dire c'est le problème de trois
personnes du des sociaux-démocrate ça je
n'accepterai pas ça et puis c'est
peut-être ceux qui se sont fait prendre
et d'autres se sont pas fait prendre
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas c'est
trop facile c'est vraiment de la
politique politicienne et je déconseille
de de le décrire comme ça en tout cas je
ne ferai pas alors le financement des
partis politiques
je sais que le rassemblement national
dit répète avant lui le Front national
que c'est pas de gaieté de cœur qui est
allé financer à l'étranger parce qu'il
n'arrivait pas à financer en France
comment s'est-il que Nathalie Arthaud se
finance en France comment fait-il
fait-il que
Eric Zemmour se finance en France il y
aurait-il un grand complot des banques
françaises animées par je ne sais qui
puisque c'était déjà avant Emmanuel
Macron et depuis pour que seul le
rassemblement national et le Front
national avant ne puisse pas se financer
dans notre pays j'ai du mal à le croire
je n'aime pas le conspirationnisme je
vous l'ai déjà dit
est-ce que ça aurait un lien avec les
problèmes de gestion du Front national
avec la mise en examen de son trésorier
je n'en sais rien je constate que seul
le Front National a fait cette démarche
d'aller en dehors de l'Union Européenne
d'abord et vers un pays très particulier
et très ingérent qui est la Russie et je
constate que les positions du
rassemblement national sur des sujets
comme la Crimée comme Boris namsov
comme le don basse sont des positions
qui sont les mêmes que la Russie il y
avait donc probablement une sympathie
qui l'a conduit je ne vois pas en quoi
la banque de la démocratie aurait changé
quoi que ce soit ce qui change quelque
chose et c'est évident c'est la force de
l'assemblée de du rassemblement national
dans l'Assemblée nationale d'aujourd'hui
mais je ne vois pas en quoi la question
de la banque de la démocratie à quoi que
ce soit à voir avec les ingérences
étrangères en tout cas pas de moins
point de vue
madame la miss merci pour cette question
vous voulez moi même revenir
vous savez
le financement c'est cette question est
vraiment importante parce que vous dites
vous vous voyez pas pourquoi le Front
national plus rassemblement national n'a
pas accès aux réseaux bancaire mais
cette question sincèrement il peut
d'ailleurs peut-être parce que tout le
monde n'est pas au courant de tout c'est
pas du tout n'est que
notamment le médiateur du crédit ou
ce pardon les rapports sur les élections
les différentes élections particuliers
qui sont présidentielles on va tester
que lorsqu'on nationale et ses candidats
même au législatives ou départemental
régional avait des difficultés
particulières
d'accès au crédit c'était des choses qui
ont été qui sont objectivement
renseignés par les institutions de la
République avec des nuances évidemment
il s'agit pas dire que c'est une
persécution mais il y a constate une
difficulté d'accès d'ailleurs même ce
Pérou qui est à l'origine de la banque
de la proposition d'avoir de la
démocratie n'a pas contesté qu'il y
avait
[Musique]
une fois plus laquelle de ces opinions
mais vous comprendrez qu'on peut estimer
que c'est pas non plus prouvé voilà et
que il est quand même moi j'aurais on
peut aussi s'interroger sur le fait que
le premier ou deuxième ça dépend très
compétition enfin une grande un grand
parti d'opposition en France n'est pas
accès à un financement il me semble que
c'était le la motivation de la banque de
de la de la démocratie vous savez que la
loi a été votée et que il y avait une
autorisation d'ordonnance pour la mettre
en place cette banque qu'elle n'a pas
été mise en place donc quand même est-ce
que vous estimez un peu cette question
mais est-ce que vous dites ça n'aura
rien changé on peut estimer que le
rassemblement national ou moi à l'époque
était adlf qui avait des problèmes de
financement c'est semblable
le fait d'accéder à la banque de la
démocratie moi par exemple vous savez ça
m'a une élection qui m'a coûté à titre
personnel plus de 100000 euros à payer
bon donc l'accès à une banque de la
démocratie c'est pas c'est pas ou à une
banque une égalité dans les systèmes
bancaire c'est pas anodin et d'une
manière générale vous savez d'ailleurs
qu'il y a un problème général d'accès
maintenant au système bancaire pour les
partis politiques visiblement d'après ce
que d'immédiateur parce que les banques
en fait c'est pas un grand complot vous
avez raison ne veulent pas de problème
c'est à dire pas de vagues et d'autres
ne veulent plus se mêler du financement
de la politique ce qui pose enfin ce qui
peut poser problème dans une démocratie
je comprends que ce sujet vous passionne
mais je ne crois pas que ce soit l'objet
de cette commission d'enquête et ça
n'est pas
je ne suis pas venu pour parler du
financement des partis politiques
français ce n'est pas ma compétence ce
n'est pas là-dessus que j'ai travaillé
et donc être pour ou contre la banque de
la démocratie ça peut être un sujet
passionnant d'un débat que nous aurions
un autre jour moi je suis venu
m'interroger devant vous sur le fait que
un parti ait fait le choix
de se mettre dans la main d'une banque
russe
je à ma connaissance
la société actuelle auprès de qui le
rassemblement national est endetté
à reporter l'échéance du prêt à 2028 il
y a peut-être des choses que je ne
connais pas je vous avoue que je ne suis
pas le rassemblement national et sont
prêts tous les jours
vous même vous l'avez dit vous avez été
à debout la France c'est même là que
nous nous étions connus lorsque j'étais
ministre et que j'organisais les
consultations citoyennes pour l'Europe
ce n'est pas le choix qui a fait debout
la France
vous dites que vous avez eu des
difficultés de financement mais que vous
avez fait un autre choix il est toujours
possible de faire un autre choix je
constate
et je ne vous cache pas pour le déplorer
qu'un parti politique français se soit
c'est endetté auprès d'une d'une banque
russe je trouve ça particulier
sachant ce qu'est cette banque ce qu'est
aujourd'hui l'entreprise qui a repris ce
prêt je trouve ça particulier et j'irai
jusqu'à dire que je trouve ça
embarrassant
ce que font les banques en France
elles le font souverainement est-ce
qu'elles sont prudentes excessivement
prudentes frileux
libre à chacun
de mettre le casque significatif qu'il
souhaite
aujourd'hui mon travail consiste au
Parlement européen à m'assurer que les
industries de défense européennes
puissent accélérer le rythme de leur
production et je constate que les
banques en Europe sont prudentes
peut-être frileuse sur les industries de
défense je veux je le regrette
je n'en conclue pas pour autant qu'il y
a un grand complot
je constate qu'en effet le rassemblement
national fait savoir et répète depuis
plusieurs années qu'il a des difficultés
de financement je constate aussi que
c'est un particulier difficulté de
gestion vous me dit d'autres parties en
ont mais en plus se faire financer c'est
possible je ne suis pas en situation de
vous donner d'explications je n'en suis
pas experte
le rapporteur
oui je voulais juste m'immiscer
rapidement dans ce débat qui est
effectivement me semble être en dehors
du champ de compétence de la commission
d'enquête telle que la proposition de
résolution qui est passée et au bureau
et à la commission des lois le
stipule et je pense qu'effectivement
madame l'oiseau n'est pas venu pour
parler des manières de rénover notre
démocratie ou de rénover le financement
des partis politiques français ou des
campagnes électorales françaises moi je
suis juste un tout petit peu
troublé que ce sujet qui portait avec
une certaine insistance
lors d'autres distances cet après-midi
sur la banque de la démocratie viennent
dans une audition nous parlons beaucoup
des ingérences étrangères des stratégies
d'influence d'interférences et
d'ingérence de la part notamment du
régime de Poutine et de l'alignement que
nous pouvons factuellement constater à
travers des votes au Parlement européen
des déplacements
insistants notamment à la faveur de
consultation entre guillemets qui n'en
sont pas dans la Crimée annexée
également par la Russie etc de tel ou
tel membre du rassemblement national
voilà donc je trouve qu'il y a une
certaine confusion et je pense que cette
troublant de devoir ce sujet sur voilà
la banque de la démocratie s'invitait à
ce moment-là parce que à contrario on
pourrait en trouver on pourrait en tirer
des conclusions désagréables
non mais je précise pourquoi j'ai posé
cette question en tant que président de
la commission est assez simple madame
Loiseau tout à l'heure a mentionné par
exemple le manque de financement de la
recherche française comme une fragilité
de notre système face à des ingérences
étrangères si les partis politiques
français ne sont pas financés à égalité
c'est ce que j'estime on peut estimer
que c'est une fragilité donc estime que
la question que j'ai posée est la banque
de la démocratie comme il y aura une
banque de la recherche
pourrait résoudre ce problème on voit
pas en quoi
en quoi cette question pose problème
madame Loiseau dit a répondu librement
et pas troublante
l'accusation et d'ailleurs
lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle le prêt a été mentionné
même au débat présidentiel donc il faut
bien un rôle dans nos processus
démocratiques et donc le fait qu'il
soit comment
pardon oui le fait qu'il soit que je
sais d'établir ce que j'estimais d'effet
ou qu'ils ne sont pas des faits des
preuves qui sont pas des preuves me
semble totalement dans notre sujet mais
je prends acte du fait que ça faisait
que que vous ayez trouvé que c'était
troublant mais je pense pas avoir manqué
à ma fonction voilà l'oiseau
personne ne manque à sa fonction mais
que le financement russe de Madame Le
Pen ou du rassemblement national d'abord
du Front national était émotionné à
l'occasion d'une campagne où Madame Le
Pen Briguet
le suffrage des Français pour être
président de la République
est évidemment pertinent à partir du
moment où
une responsable d'un parti politique et
non pas
responsable au gouvernemental multiplie
les déplacements en Russie ou Madame Le
Pen est allé énormément de mes 12 2013
2014 2015
c'est
en tant que diplomate je ne suis pas
allé aussi souvent en Russie que Madame
Le Pen je tiens à vous le dire
le fait que elle est pris des positions
aussi particulières écoutez sur le crash
du vol mh17
qui est une tragédie qui a touché des
passagers en particulier néerlandais ça
reste un traumatisme pour ce pays que
Madame Le Pen ait choisit de dire je
refuse d'exonérer les Ukrainiens
c'est quand même exactement ce que
disait les autorités russes à l'époque
et c'était faux elle s'est
formidablement trompée
que on trouve dans le hacking fait par
les hackers de anonymeuse un échange qui
n'a jamais été contestée par personne
alors peut-être que personne n'y a porté
attention mais je ne crois pas parce
qu'on l'a vu dans des documentaires en
France il a été repris à plusieurs
reprises un échange entre un
hacker russe et un membre de
l'administration présidentielle russe
disant Marine Le Pen a reconnu le
résultat du référendum en Crimée elle
n'a pas déçu nos attentes nous devons la
récompenser je cite pas tout à fait de
textos parce que je n'ai pas le texte
sous les yeux mais vous pouvez le
retrouver il est notamment dans mon
livre
et que juste après on voit arriver le
pré russe pardonnez-moi
c'est un sujet qui mérite de figurer
dans un débat de la campagne
présidentielle si Madame Le Pen ne
souhaitait pas devenir chef de l'État ce
serait sans doute différent
mais c'est tout de même comme le disait
madame la rapporteur quelque chose qui
sème le trouble
madame
qui sont qui viennent à l'esprit vous
pouvez estimer que que
le moi j'ai essayé d'établir dans le cas
de cette commission les faits et les
questions qui essaient de vous poser
c'est de comprendre de préciser ce que
vous allez vous dire ce n'est pas
contesté
moi aussi de de d'avancer dans la bonne
information de nos compatriotes c'est la
ligne que je me suis fixée en étant
comique présente cette commission et je
sais de la mener y compris quand cela
touche et tout le monde sait une force
politique dont je suis membre et quand
d'ailleurs c'est trop compliqué je me
suis déporté et je me déporterai à
nouveau qu'on les auditionneront
évidemment d'autres membres de cette
famille politique ma question d'ailleurs
vous l'avez dit c'est intéressant que
vous ayez mentionné ce déclenche parce
que c'était l'objet vraiment de ma
prochaine question c'était
c'est une fois de plus une vraie
question que je me pose quand on a j'ai
posé d'ailleurs ça s'est transparent
parce que je pose souvent les mêmes
questions à différentes personnes
auditionner
le la Russie donc fait acte de
propagande de nombreuses manières vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs dans votre exposé
elle cherche à semer la division dans
nos sociétés on peut estimer que dans
leur panel de méthodes pourraient aussi
trouve semer le doute sur la sincérité
des hommes et des femmes politiques dans
les différentes démocraties y compris de
l'opposition et y compris des opposants
aux différents gouvernements et le fait
que des
oligarques russes prétendent avoir de
l'influence sur tel ou telle personne
prétendre soutenir telle ou telle
personne prétendre mener vous l'avez dit
il y a une opération qui a réussi une
opération qui a échoué
peut-être de une vérité ça c'est à la
justice c'est pas moi de l'établir ou
c'est aux personnes compétentes au
service par exemple mais on ne peut pas
considérer que quand ils disent quelque
chose c'est par nature va aussi vrai et
en tout cas aussi vrai que ce que dirait
un responsable élu dans une démocratie
et en qui on doit on peut avoir plus de
confiance que dans les propos
d'oligarque russe donc vous avez
qualifié les méfaits
vous avez parfaitement raison et se
mettre à croire comme parole d'évangile
des propos tenus par des oligarques
russes serait forme de contradiction
avec ce que je dis par ailleurs
en revanche lorsque
des
échanges sont hackés c'est un peu
différent puisqu'il n'est pas destiné à
être rendu public
et en revanche quand en 2017 Vladimir
Poutine choisit de recevoir avec les
honneurs une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle
forme d'ingérence je crois que la
personne ne peut en douter et personne
ne peut douter qu'il l'a reçu que
d'ailleurs Madame Le Pen a eu des propos
très élogieux à son égard à cette
occasion 2017 je rappelle que on a déjà
vu le comportement de Vladimir Poutine
en Géorgie au dombases en Crimée en
Syrie
et un certain nombre
de comportements de politique intérieure
qui pouvait susciter un langage que je
qualifierais de plus mesurer de plus
diplomatique comme celui qui a par
exemple le chef de l'État lorsqu'il a
été conduit à rencontrer
Vladimir Poutine
merci madame la ministre qui sont
suivants sauf si même le rapporteur
c'est une question entre lui ma question
suivante excusez-moi je vais la
retrouver oui
cette question a été un peu abordée par
Monsieur Leroy mais j'aimerais la
l'élargir
quand il s'agit des personnalités qui
ont fait ce qui ont se sont rendus
remettre en cause les faits que vous
avez donné vous l'ayez au restaurant
national ce qui est vrai quand il s'agit
c'est un nombre d'entreprises dans votre
livre que dont j'ai lu autant de
passages que j'ai pu dans le temps
imparti
j'essaie de tout honnête dans ce que je
fais
monsieur poteau di Borgo vous ne
mentionnez pas sa famille politique
monsieur Leroy vous n'avez pas mentionné
alors vous avez donné des arguments mais
on peut estimer qu'il aurait quand même
eu sa place parce que c'est un livre
vraiment je le dis sans aucune ironie
dense et très renseignée
qu'il aurait eu sa place une fonction
importante monsieur Leroy et d'ailleurs
toujours actif en fait on Loir-et-Cher
donc c'est pas juste à retraité de la
politique
et de la même façon par exemple vous ne
mentionnez pas une personnalité
importante j'ai mentionné à plusieurs
reprises c'est pas non plus réserver
votre audition et d'ailleurs il sera
auditionné c'est comme Monsieur Leroy ça
savoir ce qui nous écoute monsieur Laura
soit Disney c'est Jean-Pierre
Chevènement
vous le connaissez très bien je pense
parce que va très bien vous connaissez
très personnalité politique c'est une
personnalité politique de premier plan
d'ailleurs d'autres personnes
auditionnées ont mentionné le fait que
sa fondation aspublica et une autre dont
j'ai oublié le nom ont beaucoup
travaillé sur la Russie avec un
positionnement très documenté
très affirmé
que je pense vous ne partagez pas mais
on dirait si vous partagez ou pas
l'orientation des travaux de la
fondation de cechevénement j'ai
découvert pendant nos travaux de la
commission qu'il avait reçu en 2017
alors que Monsieur Macron a déjà élu
un des plus hautes distinctions de
honorifique lors de l'amitié
russe remis remise personnellement par
Monsieur Poutine avec un discours dont
on trouve la traduction en français moi
je ne parle pas russe mais si la
traduction est mauvaise il faut nous
faire savoir de toute façon monsieur
savoir puisque il sera auditionné
monsieur Poutine parle d'action d'amitié
concrète le mot concrète et entre
guillemets
monsieur Chevènement ayant un poste à
responsabilité pendant plusieurs années
comme représentant spécial de la France
en Russie
et cette comment dire cette anecdote ou
se fait ne figure pas dans votre vague
vous n'avez pas mentionné aujourd'hui je
ne vous ai pas entendu mais une fois que
je peux exhaustif mais
être choqué quand monsieur levénement a
soutenu monsieur Macron il y a un accord
électoral entre
Renaissance et le mouvement monsieur
Chevènement si il y a trois députés il y
a trois candidatures je vais de
mantistes
mais non mais est-ce que je peux poser
ma question
il y a eu trois candidatures
issus de moi monsieur je suis
actuellement donc le secrétaire de
respectica dont une élu a été élu donc
siège dans nos rang de la manière
majorité précédente entre
2012 et 2017 qui est à voter contre
aussi une résolution à voter pour une
résolution contre les sanctions liées la
première la première vague de sanction
donc c'est une affirmation ancienne
voilà ma question c'est de la manière
quand vous parlez de Monsieur fraudeur
quand vous parlez du scandale du Qatar
donc je conviens parfaitement qu'il ne
doit pas éclipser le reste d'ailleurs
dans nos travaux le scandale du Qatar
n'éclipse pas du tout le reste bien au
contraire
vous ne mentionnez pas non plus que ça a
une influence soit sur le PSE soit sur
le SPD de manière disproportionnée donc
ma question est très simple c'est
pourquoi est-ce que vous n'appliquez pas
le même régime à tous les mouvements
politiques c'est à dire liés le parti
politique dont ils sont issus avec la
personnalités politiques que vous mettez
en cause
alors vous l'avez dit vous n'avez pas eu
le temps de lire tout mon livre et je ne
vous emporte absolument pas la critique
il fait déjà 519 pages
donc il n'est pas aussi exhaustif que
certains l'imaginent je n'ai pas pu
parler absolument de tout et de tous
je le
confesse très volontiers
et je suis
aussi
étonné de la bienveillance
de Monsieur chevetement vis-à-vis de la
Russie que de celle de Monsieur
Mélenchon que j'ai cité dans cette
audition
que de celle de Monsieur Zemo de
Monsieur De Villiers de Monsieur Pozzo
di Borgo que vous avez raison de citer
et qui est présent dans mon livre
en tant notamment que responsable du
dialogue franco-rus avec Monsieur
Mariani
bien sûr que cette bienveillance au fur
et à mesure
de ce que la Russie montre de son
comportement ne peut qu'être troublante
je me contenterai de dire que si j'ai
davantage
documenté certains personnages
politiques par rapport à d'autres
je me suis concentré sur ce qui ont des
ambitions politiques pour l'avenir je ne
crois pas mais je peux en tromper je ne
crois pas que j'en tire championnement
soit candidat aux prochaines élections
présidentielles
je ne crois pas que ce soit non plus le
cas de Monsieur pozzotti Borgo
je pense donc que même si je ne partage
pas leur lecture sur la Russie
ta nécessité de développer dans mes
propos comme je l'ai fait dans mon livre
la connaissance que j'ai acquise
de l'intérêt que la Russie de leur porte
et de l'intérêt qu'ils portent à la
Russie moins grande
mais je vais vous mettre très à l'aise
ce que vous mentionnez madame Bechtel
qui est aussi été ma prédécesseur comme
directrice de Lena d'ailleurs
avec qui j'avais pas mal de désaccords
notamment celui-là mais pas seulement je
vais vous mettre très à l'aise parlons
de la Chine et parlons d'un ancien
député de la République en marche
parlons de guantan
je ne suis pas à l'aise
avec les choix qui avait été fait par
burundam d'être aussi proche du front
uni c'est-à-dire d'une branche du Parti
communiste chinois je vous le dis très
simplement
comme je pourrais le lui dire s'il était
en face de moi
ça n'est pas une étiquette politique qui
doit me mettre des oeillères et je pense
que les invitations dont brantan a fait
l'objet en Chine sont des éléments qu'il
est nécessaire de porter à la
connaissance de nos compatriotes et j'en
parle d'ailleurs dans mon livre
ma dernière question sera aussi une
question que j'ai posée à plusieurs
personnes c'est auditionner c'est
une interrogation que j'ai il voudrait
avoir votre votre avis sur mon
interrogation
enfin votre observation c'est que vous
avez reproché enfin vous avez constaté
la présence d'un nombre de députés
d'euros députés de 9 c'est ça
aurait député Rennes dans en Crimée
occupé le contact la présence de Madame
Le Pen à Moscou
on peut estimer que les conséquences
dans la vie concrète
des Russes des Français des Européens en
général de ces actions tu es assez
limité sur la suite des événements
d'un autre côté on a des relations qui
ont été faites avec le régime russe si
je prends pour la France à partir des
années 2000 à partir de notamment de
l'amitié en tout cas affiché comme tel
entre Jacques Chirac et Vladimir Poutine
là vous avez raison c'est qu'il y a un
certain nombre de faits qui se sont
passés depuis la finale madame
politoscaia l'élection avec le rocher
vous avez tout à fait énoncé les faits
les conteste absolument pas bien au
contraire
mais même avec ces faits là
les relations économiques se sont se
sont été très importantes y compris que
les sociétés qui avaient besoin de
l'autorisation de l'État pour intervenir
je pars enfin la liste par exemple ce
qui était GDF Suez puis engie
une part de capital entre 20 entre 18 et
25% selon les moments et a été autorisé
à investir dans un stream 1 finances
stream 2 donc à une période quand même
très tardive
total n'est pas une entreprise d'État
enfin les liens entre total et l'État
français sont quand même forts ne
serait-ce que d'influence a été autorisé
à faire des investissements
considérables
en Russie que vous connaissez fort bien
Renault dont 10% du capital est public a
été autorisé à avoir une courte
entreprise
en Russie très importante
pourrait le mistral que vous avez cité
l'annulation du Mistral s'il a été
annulé c'est qu'il a été vendu pas par
des responsables du Front national à
l'époque mais par Nicolas Sarkozy vous
avez mentionné monsieur Fillon il se
trouve quand même qu'il était premier
ministre quand cette vente a été faite
et donc moi si vous voulez je ne remets
pas en cause ce que vous avez dit ou je
le comment dire je ne je ne vous
conteste pas le droit et ça c'est
évident mais même en tant qu'adversaire
politique parce que faut pas se leurrer
de contester tous les choix qui a été
fait par Astro national ce que je
m'étonne et j'essaie de rester de la
plus bonne fois que je peux en tant
qu'être humain là dedans c'est qu'on ne
met pas en rapport ce que vous contestez
de la part des dirigeants du rassemble
un seul que vous avez mis en cause avec
quand même la gravité
l'ampleur des choix qui ont été faits
par au pouvoir par les dirigeants
politiques en faveur ou avec le régime
russe il aurait été très bien possible
de dire à Total d'investir de dire à
Renaud comme je le fais vous avez
d'investir ailleurs que engie aurait
très bien pu ne pas investir dans nos
stream 1 et 2 et d'investir dans
d'autres gisements gasiés qui sont
nombreux à travers le monde
et que donc c'est bien et que vous êtes
député européenne et je le sais
d'ailleurs que c'est quelque chose que
que vous contestez ce que je le lis le
vous suit
ces décisions par rapport par ailleurs
par exemple en Allemagne ont mis
l'Europe dans une situation de
dépendance envers le régime russe
extrêmement grave et préoccupant dont on
a connu tous les conséquences
cette année et ce ne sont pas les
dirigeants du rassemble national qui ont
fait ses choix politiques
il est certain que au moment où nous
parlons le rassemblement national n'a
pas eu le pouvoir permettez-moi en tant
que adversaire politique et
respectueusement de me réjouir et donc
on ne peut pas lui
imputer
des choix de gouvernement
que je ne partage pas vous le savez
parce que vous avez dit par ailleurs je
l'ai dit par ailleurs notamment sur Nord
Stream 2 je pense qu'il y a eu un
aveuglement collectif européen dont
Vladimir Poutine c'est tellement bien
servi qu'il a attendu que le gazoduc
soit terminé pour lancer l'invasion de
l'Ukraine
le fait que des choix
mal informés
étaient faits par des gouvernements
divers
doit-il
[Musique]
dédouaner ce qui ayant vu tout cela
continuent à contester
la nécessité d'envoyer davantage d'un
melon à l'Ukraine
est-ce que c'est rassurant de penser au
vu
de là où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
c'est à dire d'une guerre d'invasion qui
met à l'ordre international qui veut
remplacer la règle du droit par la loi
du plus fort
des crimes de guerre peut-être des
crimes contre l'humanité une un mandat
d'arrêt de la Cour pénale internationale
est-ce que vraiment
la mesure de ce qui s'est passé a été
prise par certains
je n'en suis pas complètement convaincu
et là je suis inquiète parce
qu'effectivement le parti que vous
représentez je constate que ici à
l'Assemblée nationale on peut présider
une commission d'enquête et revendiquer
sa couleur politique ce qui n'est pas
mon cas quand je préside ma
sous-comission au Parlement européen où
je m'efforce à l'impartialité mais
chaque Parlement a sa culture
je m'inquiète
de continuer à voir le rassemblement
national au Parlement européen jouait au
Chaya la souris c'est à dire que là où
avant il votait contre tout ce qui
concernait l'Ukraine maintenant il ne
pas prend pas par au vote il vote avec
ses pieds c'est son choix mais c'est un
drôle de choix franchement et ça l'isole
y compris dans son groupe politique
sa m'inquiète ça m'interroge des choses
suffisamment graves se sont passées
alors je sais vous avez voté sur le lot
de mort il y a quelques jours comme
l'écrasante majorité des députés de
cette Assemblée et je vous en félicite
il s'agissait de crimes de Staline il
s'agissait pas de ce de Vladimir Poutine
je garde un malaise
qui est une opinion politique que je
place très clairement dans le cadre des
opinions politiques où nous ne nous
rejoignons pas
je garde un malaise sur ce choix
d'un parti politique parce que je
n'entends personne dire autre chose à
l'intérieur du rassemblement national je
constate que Thierry Mariani peut
continuer à dire ce qu'il dit à faire
les voyages qu'il fait quand il ne va
pas en Russie il va en Syrie de Bachar
el-Assad ce sont quand même des choix
extraordinairement particulier je n'ai
jamais entendu un communiqué du
rassemblement national disant lui c'est
lui ou c'est nous
ou le mettant en demeure
d'avoir moins de sympathie pour le
régime russe
c'est cela que je constate et c'est cela
qui m'interroge comme m'interroge les
choix d'un de l'ancien sénateur pozzodi
Borgo comme m'interroge d'autres choix
faits dans d'autres partis politiques
quand il s'agit d'un régime autoritaire
qui dans ces discours expriment son
inversion pour ce que nous sommes en
tant que démocratie européenne
merci Madame la Ministre écoutez je n'ai
plus de questions
bien écoutez je vous remercie madame
Loiseau toute sincérité pour le temps
que vous avez accordé pour la qualité
des caisses des réponses que vous avez
pas laquelle
vous avez apporté à notre commission
même quand les échanges ont pu être
franc voilà mais j'estime que son franc
et vous l'avez dit vous-même puis ils
sont francs puissant transparents ils
sont transparents plus ils sont francs
voilà donc je vous remercie de d'être
venu d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
remercie l'administration pour
l'organisation et le suivi de cette
commission je le remercie madame le
rapporteur et les commissaires présents
le salut le travail de la presse le plan
est allé votre collaboratrice qui est
aussi suivi les travaux je vous souhaite
une bonne fin de journée et la séance
est levée